thank you and good morning everyone
welcome to this meeting of mid-suffolk
district council development control
meeting a
uh before this meeting starts we will be
holding a one minute silence
uh in remembrance of prince philip the
duke of edinburgh
who passed away last friday so could if
i ask everyone just to observe one
minute silence please
thank you
uh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much everyone okay we
have mr echols butler who's joined us
um if we could let him in please robert
yes rob i've just done that okay
thank you um okay so we'll move on um
so thank you everyone and welcome as i
said earlier if i could ask everyone
just to please make sure you are on mute
uh when you're not speaking can i just
remind us before we get going at some of
the domestic arrangements for today's
meeting
please ensure your microphones are muted
when you're not speaking
and that you do not interrupt other
speakers members reminded not to use the
messaging chat function during the
meeting
unless it is to report a pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest
or to notify the chair that you wish to
make a proposal
members are reminded they should not
have an alternative communication lines
open
such as other teams chats or use the
emoji functions
that if you are contacted by a third
party during the applications
you should please bring us to the
attention of our legal advisor
please remember that if you are
attending the meeting to speak and you
do persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
and additionally you'll be invited to
speak and ask questions by myself
during the meeting by using the hands up
function
we will be exec using the e-vote
of e-voting for this meeting if you're
experiencing any poor connection issues
in the first instance we would ask you
please try turning off your camera
and if this does not work please turn
off all incoming view
video and if you look at the three bars
at the top of the screen
uh the three dots at the top of the
screen on the toolbar you'll find more
information on how to do that
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live on the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make representation to the
meeting today you will be deemed by the
council to
consent it to having been recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded i'd just like to
use this opportunity just to introduce
some of the officers who are with us
today
first up we have mr ian de prez who's
our legal advisor
ian good morning morning chairman next
we have john payton
g who's the area planning manager good
morning john
good good morning uh we have robert
carmichael who we've already
met earlier who's our government support
officer uh we also have claire philpott
who's with us as well good morning
claire who's here as the governance
officer as well
and then good morning and we have two
case officers alex scott and samantha
summers who will be presenting the
applications
before us um in mid suffolk uh
district council the local members may
speak on an application that comes
before us
uh but may not vote uh and on this
application we will have uh three ward
members we have harry richson and wendy
turner
and james caston so i'll now move
swiftly on to the agenda
please and the first item on the agenda
is apologies for absence and
substitutions i now ask the governance
officer
to roll call for the members present
thank you very much chair so if members
could please respond
um with their presence this morning
my list is just on the wrong page so um
councillor rachel ebert
present councillor john field president
councilman matthew hicks
president council sarah mansell present
pastor john matheson president council
richard mayer
that's the dave muller president and
councillor tim passmore
present thank you chair we are all
present
thank you very much agenda item number
two is to receive declarations of
pecuniary or non-pecuniary interest by
members
are there any to declare a council
mansell
uh thank you chair i i just thought i'd
better mention that the
um development in uh horsley norton
uh has been um discussed for some time
um and it goes back to when i was the
ward member in norton
not this particular application but
development on that site in particular
okay thank you very much um any anyone
else wish
to declare any peculiar non-pecuniary
interests no
yes chair johnson yes this is the usual
thing i i
am the county councillor at the moment
for the area
of branford so for the second
application
and obviously in such role i have heard
discussions at the parish council of
this issue
uh i also used to be the district
councillor for that area but that's i
need to go
thank you very much okay any other
decorations of interest by members
nope okay thank you very much agenda
item number three is declarations
of lobbying uh i have been lobbied
um on the uh uh second item
uh with photos and i suspect counselor
manson counselor muller
uh i've been lobbied on both
applications
i suspect a lot of us have i have uh
councillor field councillor eben
yes sir photographs and things on the
second name okay
cancer even yes the same thank you same
okay thank you very much
okay agenda item number four was
declarations of any personal site visits
anyone got any to declare councillor
mansell and then councillor mayor
um i i happened to be cycling past
hall's lane site on sunday morning on my
way to berry so
yes i saw the site
okay thank you very much and councillor
mayor yes i visited the hall's lane
tonight
okay thank you very much um
agenda item number five is to uh
confirmation in the minutes of the
meeting that was held
um on the 17th of march um
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes that anyone
wishes to raise
no okay could i have a proposer and a
seconder
for the minutes please counselor
muller yes i'm happy to propose thank
you chair
uh who was that councillor matheson
thank you councilman
okay um so i will now ask the governor's
office to conduct an electronic vote
thank you chair members could please go
to the modern.gov app in there
go to sorry if they could go to today's
agenda in the modern.gov app
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner this will bring up the
subsection of attendance and voting
and if you click on that it will show
the list of votes before us today
with the current vote in progress being
shown in a light blue color
vote is now in progress
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is eight votes for and
is unanimous
thank you okay thank you the minutes of
the meeting have obviously now been
confirmed
and they'll be signed at the next
practical opportunity
okay agenda item number six to receive
notifications and petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme have we received any please
okay so that's um no petitions received
chair
okay thank you very much so we'll move
on to schedule of planning applications
the first application before us is
dc2100662 land off horse lane norton
now invite the case officer alex scott
to introduce the application to the
committee
over to you thank you very much chair
and uh good morning
um i'll just try and present my screen
and the presentation
hopefully everybody can see that
slideshow from beginning
right at the moment we haven't got it in
slideshow we've got
or at least i there we go that's fine
now it's nice aren't you
yeah that's fine yes okay thank you
thank you
um well yes uh this is uh item number
seven
a in in the papers application reference
dc
oblique 21 oblique 0062
and it is a outline planning application
with all matters reserved
apart from access for the erection of
nine dwellings
vehicular access and pedestrian links
that land off horse lane in norton
and i said out in the first page of the
report
the application follows a previous
refusal
on the site and additional land for 20
dwellings
which was assessed by this committee on
the 16th of october 2019.
and the application was refused for the
reasons as set out
which involved highway safety
uh pedestrians and vehicles uh conflict
on
horse lane and additional wear and tear
on horse lane because of that
resultant conflict so
that is a material consideration in the
assessment of this
this current application
and this first slide shows the location
of norton
within the district for the avoidance of
doubt
and the approximate location of the site
within the village
and i can just get my
cursor showing no it's not ah there it
is
apologies uh so horse lane
is here and the site approximately here
and access would be onto horse lane we
then have
the main ixworth road running through
the village
to the uh to the east we have
uh heath road to the south
and then the thurston road to the north
which connects
uh to uh horse lane to the north
this is a constraints uh planning
constraints map
um the shot that the site is here
in in orange uh it lies outside of the
settlement boundary of the village which
is highlighted here
in this brown color and the site is
uh outside of uh any flood zones which
are
off here to the uh to the to the west
as outlined with these blue hatched
areas so flood zone two
in light blue flood zone three in dark
blue
there is a public bridal way to the
north
of the site accessed off horse lane
which is
relevant to this application and
to village residents who use horse lane
to access this ride away which leads
to a to a nature reserve which is which
is off the plan
to the west of the site
also shown on this plan are listed
buildings
this orange color denoting uh grade two
listed buildings and
trees covered by tree preservation
orders but uh as can be
seen none directly affect the proposal
site this is an aerial
view of the site and a
wider view showing paul's lane
and the site location plan provided with
the
application and it shows the
proposal site with all associated land
edged in red and
we have included with the application
three pedestrian links one
through the site and land within the
applicant's ownership
exiting onto ixworth road
to the east we have another
along the along the western side
of horse lane the built-up part of
horde's lane
to heathrow to the south
and then finally another pedestrian link
to the north this time on the western
side
of the rural part of horse lane which is
proposed to link up to the
to the bride away on the opposite side
of the road
so that pedestrians would be able to
traverse that clear of the
the metal part of the the highway where
the vehicles would
uh drive and we also have
uh five vehicle passing bays proposed
within horse lane uh four
to the rural part to the north and one
in front of the dwellings
to the south of the site within the
built-up
part of uh of horse lane
let's see these next slides show the um
the proposed site layout um
and as this is outlined the uh
the layout is indicative but it's um it
demonstrates how
uh how nine dwellings may be uh provided
on the site
and the proposed access which does form
part of this application would be
central to the site in uh in horse lane
and the application does include for the
uh the widening of [ __ ] lane
immediately to the uh
to the site frontage and
part of me um again the the alterations
proposed uh
two horse lane so we have a a two meter
wide
footpath to the the eastern side
of wars the rural part of horse lane and
the five uh passing bays
and uh to the south we have a uh
another uh footpath uh proposed to the
this time the western side of
paul's lane to the dwelling frontages
and
one passing bay in front of the uh one
of the dwellings here at
charles field
and this is a close-up of the
proposed passing bay and
and footpath proposed so we have
a a proposed
increase of the rural part of the
highway to 4.1 meters that's an increase
of 1.2 meters
from the existing and then there would
be a
two meter wide footpath along the verge
uh on the other side of the of the road
uh just for reference this is the uh the
proposed layout for
the uh previous applications for 20
dwellings
which was uh was refused and
subsequently appealed
and dismissed by the planning inspector
for the reasons i set out there'll be
incred increased
highway safety issues on on horse lane
now at um at this point i think it's
important to note that the previous
application
proposed one uh passing bay
on on the built-up area part of uh
of horse lane um but at this point no
footpaths were proposed to the north
the south along horse lane and no
additional passing bays in the rural
parts of
of horse lane however the
footpath connection to exworth road was
proposed at that point so
yes the the new um the new
infrastructure proposed as part of the
current application
would be the footpath to pause lane and
the additional passing bays to
uh to the rural pla parts of horse lane
if that's
that's helpful onto some photographs for
you
this photograph shows the horse lane
junction
with with heath road
and this is a view back up uh the
built-up
part of uh horse lane towards heath road
which is uh in the distance
and an opposite view there and for
reference the proposed footpath would be
along the verge in front of these
dwellings and the proposed passing bay
in front of the
the second dwelling on the right at
charles field
as you can see there
and this is the the site frontage
pause lane and some photographs
along the frontage of the site
a site frontage reverse view looking
out to the rural parts of horse lane
in the distance
and this is a photograph of the rural
part of
horse lane and the highway at
present measures
apologies um i thought i did have the
figure
um
yes sorry um two points 2.9 meters
approximately the width of the uh the
existing highway in
um there are parts of horse lane so 2.9
meters and that is proposed to be
increased by 1.2 meters
to 4 meters at the point of the passing
bays
to the uh to the left of your screen as
you uh as you see it
and the proposed footpath um two meters
wide
within the verge um to this side
and um as measured on site we believe
there is uh sufficient space there and
highways have confirmed that
as i'll come on to uh in just a moment
um also um as is relevant with this
photograph there have been several uh
consulting responses um noting the
the difference in uh in sight levels
from the level of the road in the rural
part to ports lane
and the grass verge and i think this
photograph
demonstrates that that
change in levels
this is a view of ixworth road
and where the proposed footpath would
emerge
in approximately this location next to
the
applicant's property at suffolk
house and there is a an existing large
verge here and
your officers consider this would be a
an improvement to the existing situation
for pedestrians who
have to negotiate uh heath road
and uh cross at a busy uh crossroads at
the moment
and uh yes this would um be
um of a benefit to uh to all users
let me consider
and this uh this last slide shows
um the uh
the land uh within uh highways control
so edged in light green here is all land
within uh
county highways control and this plan
has been provided by
uh suffolk county council highways and
is uh included in the
like the late papers uh for your for
your information
and the land available
for the footpath is a minimum
of uh 1.63 metres
at the narrowest point here
and as is also set out in your late
papers
highways have clarified that they do
consider
there is room to create a footpath
in this location it is noted that
there is probably not two meters
available
um to to provide that but um
they consider that uh 1.5 meters would
be
uh sufficient in this uh in this
location
and um there is 1.63 meters available
therefore your officers consider that a
provision of a 1.5 metre wide
footpath would be would be achievable in
that location
so i hope that's clear
and that concludes the presentation
chairman
as per the officer report your officer's
recommendation for
uh for approval subject to conditions
thank you
thank you very much i'm happy to open it
up to
questions to colleagues uh based on what
we've just said councilor mayor
and then councillor richardson
thanks check um reference to the
footpath
where we have the passing by at the
beginning of hall's lane
um there is a significant narrowing of
the footpath
on my plan um how wide will it be
at that point
um so sorry
at the at the initial initial part of
the footpath
along hall's lane to the northernmost
point where it goes past the passing bay
first passing though there's a sneaking
narrowing of the footpath
yes how wide will that that footpath be
at that point
all right let me just see if i can
yes there's no measurement uh given on
the plans but
um yes it would be uh
significantly narrow at that point as
shown on the plants
but highways have assessed it and raised
no objections to that
that's what i'll say okay thank you
thank you uh casa richardson you have a
question
oh thank you chair councillor mayor beat
me to it that was my question as well
so i've got nothing further to ask thank
you thanks uh councillor mansell
uh thank you chair um i'd just like to
ask
about the uh proposed footpath link uh
to the a1088 um do you happen to have
any photographs
of the visibility for pedestrians at
that point
uh as they will have to cross the busy
road
um i will just have one photograph of
that
it's previously shown on the other side
of trying to represent my
screen
david echols bachelor
is now joining
yes um so if you can see that that that
is
that's taken from the other side of the
road i presume because the pavement is
on the other side of the road
so do you have a any uh have you
stood at the point where that footpath
comes out on the 1088
um because that road looks like it's got
a slight bend in it
so is is there is there good visibility
for pedestrians
that will have to cross the road at that
point
yes i would say so and i would i would
say the
situation would be uh would be better
than the existing situation
um which uh pedestrians have to uh
stand within the public highway on heath
road at a uh at a busy crossroads
and are there any plans for any um
uh pedestrian safety improvements on
heath road
no there aren't no not on heathrow
thank you councillor field
thank you uh just a couple of points the
the
entrance onto the road i think was it
sunny side the name of the building i
think the
entrance just there i just wanted to
confirm that there's obviously a
footpath
is the road there wide enough to take
two vehicles are you one coming out and
one
turning into that uh that road or do you
need to queue in some way so that's one
point
the second point was there was something
in the papers that implied that the
passing places which are being offered
are not secured as yet
um you know they were they were a wish
but
there's nothing to say that you actually
own the land and could deliver them
those points correct or wrong
um well yes um in terms of the
the turning into the site is there
sufficient uh
space highways have assessed it and
it's their opinion that uh that it is um
in terms of the provisions of the
parking space um
those have been highlighted to be within
land which is in control of suffolk
county council
so we consider the infrastructure
proposed is deliverable
um but that would need to be insured by
way of condition
and we would want those
that infrastructure to be provided prior
to uh
to occupation of the site certainly as
suggested
thank you that's helpful thank you
thank you uh councillor field and
council eburn
[Music]
thank you very much chair thank you alex
for your presentation um i've got
three questions if i may um could you
confirm that all the
the facilities in norton are on the
other side of the a road the other side
of the 1088
so that and that there wasn't isn't any
um safe crossing um from this footpath
for children to get to school or to play
on the playing field
or to go to the pub or not the children
going to the pub obviously
so that's that so there's no there's
nothing on the
the same side of the road that the
development on there's no services
um yet from my uh having visited norton
um several times
from my understanding there are no
significant services to that side they
are
yes as uh councilory burns they can
always ask the water member
yeah so they'd have to cross the the a
road yeah okay
um thank you and um
councilman asked my question about
visibility for pedestrians
um i'm still not clear about the
difference between this application and
um
the um application that was dismissed
appeal obviously apart from the fact
that it's got less
um dwellings on this one and is it that
is the
main difference just the fact that this
one's got more passing spaces is that
the
on the on the road got on horse lane is
that the
that just seems to be the key difference
but i'm
just concerned i haven't picked up
something else there
okay um yes
if you will i have a brief list of uh
the differences
uh between the two applications uh so
we're looking at uh
a reduction from 20 dwellings to to nine
dwellings
so it would be a less intensive
development
we have the uh the two foot paths on
horse lane one to the north
and one to the south and we have uh
four additional passing bays proposed
within the rural part of [ __ ] lane
okay thank you and my last question
my last question is just could i um
could you confirm i think that the road
width as you said was 2.9
meters on horse lane um
is that how does that compare to
standard
road widths that highways would normally
expect to see is there a sort of
um there's normally a sort of standard
in terms of you know
that'd be difficult getting an hgv down
there for example um
and even with a passing space um you'd
be
pretty stuck so do you know how that
compares that 2.9 meters to a sort of
standard
road um i don't have the knowledge i'm
afraid
councillor eben i'd have to uh ask if
anybody else
does thanks thank you very much
thank you very much you want to come in
john obviously standard roads are
started essentially four meters you
often see uh larger estate roads at 5.5
meters
so uh i would say probably in rural
terms four meters is the expectations
and this is obviously
a lane so this is not anywhere near that
standard and
that has been established from the
outset okay thank you very much for that
thank you chair
thank you uh uh now uh
mr gobble do you have your hand up but
i'm afraid you don't get the opportunity
to come in at the stage
uh councillor mathison and councillor
turner
thank you chair i'll um i'll keep back
the question about the local bus
network perhaps for the ward members to
answer
um the
at 14.6 in in the report
um developer contributions generated
through
community infrastructure levy um
i thought my understanding was that this
was going to be an entirely
self-built project in which case seal
would not be
available can you help us with that
um i would suggest uh that probably a
question for the
the applicant or mr kobold representing
the the applicant um
has not been clarified within the
current application
to me i'm distinctly asking for
it to be clarified if you think that's
the best way
yeah you want to come in thank you uh
the proposal before us
is for market houses we're not aware if
they are for self build or not
um ultimately if the applicant decides
if we were to say approve this
development and later on
the applicant decide to make the self
build that is a separate
mechanism in terms of dealing with our
infrastructure team
okay thank you right thank you other
question
yeah um yeah could we go back to slide
three
please
yeah i just wanted to to clarify for
everybody
that the we see obviously at the western
edge there
thurston um sorry john this is
questions what's your question okay well
can we can we confirm where and how many
houses are um on that
on that road that's coming from thurston
to norton uh which horse lane connects
with
please
well so you're asking us to number all
the houses along that road currently
i don't think well what do you think
that's relevant john i'm really sorry
what the approvals are that may take us
some time
to do um um just
broadcasting i mean i mean if
why do you need what basis do you want
to know that question could you just do
elaborate it's concerned if it's traffic
highways have already already commented
on the use of that road
it's in our report right okay
i'll stop okay thank you councillor
turner
hi uh a question to alex sort of
following on from sarah mansell's
um questions around the entrance of the
new footpath
which is going on to the swift road
looking at the photograph you said we've
got the verge
that will be made into the footpath
but looking at the photograph it looks
like there's continuous grass it doesn't
look like a completed pedestrian
footpath
am i right in thinking am i looking at
the wrong side of the photograph
uh just a moment i'll put the photograph
up again so we can uh let's have a look
at it
yeah sorry just to
[Music]
i'm not sure which way i'm looking at it
right um where's the entrance coming out
here
approximately here yes so this is it is
a grass verge on that side
yes certainly so right okay so if people
wanted to walk further along there's
still no
completed footpath they'd have to come
across
yes they would have to cross the road
okay
thank you
okay thank you um
next up is john uh john field i have
your hand up sorry i'm not sure did you
want to come in again
yes it is intentional it's like this
time
just a brief point that on the page 13
it says the gross density of housing is
18.36
dph and the net density
is 18.36 dph are they both correct those
figures or
is there a mistake what's the real
density
um yes i would say that those figures
are uh are correct for the
0.49 area of the site nine dwellings
yes i'd say that's correct cancer field
so both the net and the gross are the
same figure
um yes
yes because it's a it's a greenfield
site the net and the uh and the growth
would be the same
just if i may come into that uh
obviously we
we perhaps should have deleted one or
the other in this case because we don't
have
waves of open space to kind of say look
uh we we don't have the capacity here of
saying it's a compact develop
development
and therefore we maybe need to be um
disconcerting about whether we take the
gross or the net in this case
it's a fairly defined area um and we
haven't got any
particular open space uh application
part of that application to consider
uh to look at the differences in density
does that
help i guess so
okay okay now i have some other hands up
uh counselor turner is that an old hand
or did you want to come back and
uh phil cobble do you have your hand up
but as i said
if you could take that down please
okay thank you so i don't have any other
questions
um so we'll move on thank you
okay so we now move to public speakers
um
i'll now ask the parish council
representative to speak and we have mr
david echols butler
you have three minutes if you'd like to
turn your microphone on and your camera
on please
are you with us
mr actually butler
now there is someone here on a phone i'm
presuming that's
that's mysterious butler but
uh we're not hearing you so you'd need
to unmute please
no mistakes but i i'm guessing you can
hear me but you can't speak to us what i
suggest is if you dial off
and dial in again uh and then hopefully
when you come in it will have unmuted
itself and you'll be able to speak maybe
we try that way
robert have you yeah yeah
my system's running very slow i've been
trying to unmute for the past 30 seconds
what i would suggest that as well um
because mr butler it seems
if you can unmute yourself if not if you
don't go out to the meeting and come
back in again and then we'll go straight
into
your speaking element so david echols
butler
yeah that's okay only take a second
start back in
i'd rather keep to the order the the
actual order rather than change the
order
possible give him a minute just to log
in
do we have mr cedric you're on the line
there yeah
loves jim hi there well we'll give we'll
give the other chap another
30 seconds if not we'll go to you then
we'll come back to him we'll just give
him another 30 seconds
thank you
no okay robert i'm we're gonna move on
um but if you if he comes in i think um
we'll just have to hold keep keep him on
hold and tell him not to mute because i
think on the phone it's harder to mute
and unbutton okay okay
so what we'll do is we'll go oh here we
go he's coming
hello uh mr trump can you hear me
you have three minutes to speak as the
parish council representative
okay thank you very much indeed i'm i'm
not going to repeat the points contained
in previous documents or at meetings i
will instead concentrate on a few
substantive issues
firstly the serious danger of the
traffic generated by the proposed nine
houses
it is not unreasonable to assume that
there could easily be an additional 18
vehicles
from the proposed development indeed i
think we all know that if the
development goes ahead
then a further application will be
submitted for a further 11
houses and thus the traffic problem will
be doubled it should be noted that there
is no pavement along both the narrow
horse lane
and heath road logically the vehicles
will travel up hall's lane
turn left onto heathrow and subsequently
up to the junction
with the busy a-1088 at this point
vehicles will mostly turn right against
the oncoming traffic
the most congested times will be at
school drop-off periods and this will be
when
there is most danger to um adults and
children alike this is already a very
dangerous junction
as testified by a police car actually
landing on the war memorial
it is very difficult to cross the a-1088
it is already very busy
and there is no zebra crossing there the
developer has put in a footpath from the
houses to 1088
councils should remember that this is an
a road at the end of the footpath there
is no pavement to stand on
just a grass bank very dangerous the
norton primary school now cater for
children up to year six
so they will may well walk to school on
their own additional vehicles increases
the danger of both adults and children
which of you would like to have a
fatality on your conscience
reject this proposed development and
safeguard the lives of norton's
residents why nine houses well of course
the developer knows that this number
means
he does not have to provide affordable
houses in addition he does
have a just he does not have to state
that there are self build houses
on an outline planning application
however i suspect most will be
and therefore he will avoid paying sill
money so there will be no benefit to the
norton community
also a maximum of five years can elapse
before their houses are finished
as a consequence the local residents
will potentially have construction
traffic polluting their lives for many
years
not to mention the increased danger to
residents from heavy lorries
for construction the excellent norton
primary school
is nearly at capacity and some children
from the proposed development will have
to be transported to other local schools
this will entail further traffic
congestion and increased pressure on
other villages
we already have a further 40 houses
approved for building in norton
not to mention additional houses which
are currently being finished off
parish council is not against
developments but we believe they should
be in suitable areas of the village
over the last 20 years there has been
considerable building in norton
we believe we do not need to build any
more houses at this time
in conclusion i should like you to
consider all previous points of
objection that the parish council has
made
and my concerns this morning you have
rejected development before
and it was also rejected on appeal i
urge you to reject it again
thank you very much for listening
mr chairman you're all dudes thank you
thank you very much but first we're
going to take some questions for you if
you could just stay there a sec
uh first of all we have councillor
muller uh we have a question for you
councillor muller
yes thank you chair uh thank you mr
rachel's butler
can you clarify the following point for
me please
um is norton school the other side
on heath road and during the school
start times and finish times do you have
a school patrol officer to help the
children cross the road at all please
firstly we don't have a a school um you
know person to cross the children that's
mostly that i think the parents tend to
take them or they they actually drive
uh down to the school or park at the um
village hall
um the school you do have to cross the
1088 from the heath road area
in order to get to the school thank you
very much thank you chair
thank you uh councillor mancer you have
a question uh thank you chair
um good morning david um i would just
like to ask
if norton parish council have conducted
a housing needs
survey in uh recent times
right okay well that was on the agenda
when we did a village plan
several years ago but to my knowledge
there has not been a
a housing need plan although
parish councils are not aware that
there's a substantial
need for any extra houses at the moment
but as i say
there are 40 already been approved okay
i think we just we just need to yeah we
just need to
yeah questions so there isn't there
isn't one thank you no
okay counselor turner
thank you chair um david what what are
the main types of vehicles that
use the 1088 would you say yeah
um i think that's quite a significant
question so far as
it is a very uh good through road many
lorries go
through lots of fans service vehicles
with all the building in various places
like first and then warp it
and elsewhere there's absolutely a lot
more traffic and
they do actually speed along at quite a
rate so
that's why i think it's incredibly
dangerous road as it is without the
extra
traffic from the development thank you
very much
okay any other questions at all uh so
yeah it's just really confirming that at
the moment norton has
uh you know i just say i'm sorry it's
only questions at this point it's not
it's not you don't have the opportunity
to speak at this stage it's just
questions
they're from uh councillor field do you
have a question for the parish council
how many houses are there in northern at
the moment
talking about an increase in nine how
many are there now well
i would it's difficult to say off top
ahead but i would say that we're talking
around about 500 houses spread out
around the whole village this is nine in
500 thank you
thank you uh any other questions for the
parish council
no okay well thank you very much for
joining us sorry about the uh the login
log out
my technology probably my computer thank
you for being persistent
okay thank you thank you thank you okay
we'll now move on um as i said to an
objector we have mr andrew sedgwick
again you have three minutes to address
the committee
thank you mr chairman the resident's
stance is that there is no support for
this proposal
except for those that seek to personally
gain financially than there in the
future
an 80 strong plus petition initially and
a substantial
quantity and quality of objections are
recorded on the portal
the only support for this application
are the dubious submissions from
associates of the applicant that have
little or no connection with the village
another example of attempts to mislead
the committee i believe
and if we apply the same integrity we'd
have thousands of objections
the 9 9 plot application is smoke and
mirrors another attempt to mislead the
panic committee and reduce the traffic
impact factors
it is obvious that the ultimate goal is
for 20 house development and i can prove
this to you mr chairman
it is my understanding that the
committee are now encouraged to consider
the balance of the necessity for the
development alongside the heart of the
community
let's be absolutely clear there is no
advantage to the village or legislative
necessity to develop no sill a school
that is and will remain full
strong objection from the parish council
and no inclusion of social housing
in contrast there is substantial
evidence of demonstrable harm
the applicant has proposed that hgv
passing place is creating a road width
of 4.1 metres at points along horse lane
including amongst the six bungalows in
horsley where the elderly and vulnerable
live
even without considering how morally
wrong some say this is cruel
the definition of a passing place is the
widening of a road to enable oncoming
vehicles to pass these passing places do
not meet that test and i can evidence
that too mr chairman
we find it ridiculous that suffolk
county highways have approved horse lane
for the quiet lane scheme while
simultaneously having no issue with
turning into a lorry park and a 20
residence development
we still believe the highways report
falls short as it fails to recognise the
dangers to the public negotiating
heathrow in the a-1088 junction
the fact is the human cost of any
approval will be felt by the occupants
of horsley and heathrow and in fact
in taipanish parents are speaking of
driving their children to school in the
village avoid walking the
obvious danger at the last 30 meters of
heath road
at the 1088 junction which is 2.7 meters
wide with no footpath
elderly horse lanes are becoming
imprisoned and speaking of moving
parents of children with special needs
at the corner of horse lane generally
concerned for their children's safety
before granting this application we had
to ask the committee to visit the area
and ask themselves if they would want
their children running this gauntlet
obviously the committee has heard that
there are still over 40 houses
authorised for construction yet to be
built in the village
and we've already seen sewage spilling
into wicksworth from already overwhelmed
victorian system
we are not nimbys the residents of heath
road have already endured 100
development of 20 to 40 houses since
2001
including jubilee close opposite horse
lane local homeowners report
absolute chaos with hgvs attempting to
access that site
and the development would create exactly
the same problems for them
the lpa have authorized a development to
the immediate south of heath road which
is about to commence
with this development to the north side
horse lane from a noise and air
pollution perspective heathrow will be
flanked
stroke sandwiched by construction for
many years
in conclusion with the overwhelming
evidence of safety concerns presented to
the committee and supported by the
appeals inspector
i would hope that they would stand by
their original decision to refuse the
application
where the committee would be aware that
we have presented
you have gone over time sorry sorry
we just i just like to say we have
presented this to our mp
she is currently concerned i'm ready
sorry all right i wait
i mean thank you thank you
okay we have some questions for you uh
first of all we have councillor field
do you have a question sorry no
counselor uh thank you chair i think my
question is actually
for the planning officers but mr
sedgwick's uh
um speech made me uh consider it
um would one of the planning officers be
able to point out on the map
where these other uh 40 homes are i've
already got permission in norton
um mr sedgwick mentioned some on the
other side of heath road and i think it
would be helpful
if the planning officer could tell us
where those are thank you
i don't have the information sorry chair
um
mr paytman g do you have any knowledge
i'm aware of the one on to the south but
i'm not sure if that's the one we're
talking about there will be one moment
um because you've got the salvation army
and the site behind
that that's got proposals on it
um we also have further along
ashfield road um and through appeal
there's been quite a few sites along
ashfield road
uh that have got approval uh that's to
the far
east of the the village center um
by the way i apologize my camera seems
to have overheated so i can't go live
um i would have to go
back over that though to find is a
specific sign for just 40 or 40
i mean i i as a relatively local person
i i do know where some of the
development sites are in norton but i
don't think the rest of the committee do
um i think the one that perhaps is most
important is the one
um near the salvation army um perhaps
that could be pointed out on the map
alex are you able to find um
yeah towards your if you can go down in
the maps of you on the
aerial plan please on the aerial plan
yes
if you go down a couple i'm just trying
to find a map wide enough to show
more the village unfortunately it's just
out it's to the south of that
keep going next one
no okay no i don't think i have anything
we haven't gone wide enough
okay okay slide four can we look at
slide four for that
slide forward unfortunately the the site
we're talking about is just beyond
the bottom of the pa the slide um so
there is a development site to the south
there
how many houses are are in that site
it's definitely not 40.
no i think that can i ask can i ask why
can i ask
can i ask why we keep asking questions
could someone just have a look
and come back with the number of sites
in the last two
three years just so that we have an idea
of a sort of figure of houses and
roughly where they're located
on where they are that'll be helpful
thank you okay country burn
um thank you chair and sorry to
interrupt her for looking for that slide
but
um could you could you just point out on
that slide
where um jubilee caught i think it was
dubli court that the um
object i mentioned is that that
development immediately south of
um horse lane on heath road
is that the one where there's that looks
like there's a tree um
jubilee court at the right at the bottom
of that slide i think it's
that um where there's a tree
preservation order noted is that
jubilee court round there jubilee close
deeply close thank you
that's that's um he's jubilee close
thank you very much for that and then
and then the development the the
planning application is below that i
think
the the salvation army one we're hearing
about yeah okay thank you very much
confirmed yeah that's what i want to
check as well thank you chair thank you
council richardson you have a question
yes please thank you chair um mr cedric
i think i wrote down that you said you
had evidence of the
further development in horse lane and
about the
difficulty with the vehicles passing
could you explain what you meant by that
thank you so just mr chairman on the
next traffic officer um
for suffolk police i i would i'm
challenging the applicant at highways to
prove
that they these passing bays actually do
function as passing base
and the evidence i'll give that a lgv
is standard at 2.5 meters rising legally
to 3 meters
a standard uh family car is 1.9 meters
and if you
a normal person would want a 20 or 30
centimeter gap to pass for straps and
just to make it comfortable
this is approaching five meters width
and i challenge the
applicant and highways to prove how five
meters fits into 4.1
and they can pass safely without
taking to the pedestrian football field
to the grass verges
um and if too long i think i i think
i've got to be careful here because
um obviously highways uses the highways
code
which late that lays out what isn't
isn't acceptable
uh but john do you want to come in on
that
i mean we the highways no one makes up
the figures it's based on
obviously on the on the on the whatever
the manual is that
highways operate from john can you
comment on that i can't really sorry i
didn't hear half the question i was so
i was trying to look up all the
applications in austin um
4.1 who determines that 4.1 is an
acceptable width i think is in essence
well ultimately um we we consult the
highways authority
they are responsible for the road and
their advice is whether they consider
given the circumstances of the nature of
the road as much as anything else
um and the speed uh whether that is
acceptable um
we have obviously guidance in respect of
uh highway uh
standards david they are guys
but is now exiting we are ultimately
relying on the highways advice they're
the experts
yeah thank you um
councillor passmore
uh thank you matthew just a very quick
one i think uh
andrew cedric mentioned this um but just
checking
there is a concern regarding foul water
and on 9.3 i don't know whether
mr sedgwick or the planning officer
could answer this
it does say that um anglian water know
there needs to be an upgrade to the
system
the problem with this is we we can hear
this but like when would there be an
upgrade to the system i don't know if
the planning officer
might be in a better position to answer
that because that is quite a serious
issue of course
we can make these yes or we as well
upgrade it but when
because we know they can be delayed does
um perhaps john payton do you have any
comment on that please
ah no i don't um we don't know anything
about that um and it would be for the
local um angry water wouldn't it i think
um who would ultimately be responsible
um
they have a duty to ensure
that the current supply is
at the right standard for the locality
as well as supply
the new uh proposals and that's the
statutory duty
um we as planning terms don't need to
get further involved in that yeah
right they're just they're statutory
consultants
okay thank you thank you councillor
matheson
do you have a question for mr cedric
carson matheson did you want to come in
sorry forgot to switch on there um mr
sedgwick mentioned
a petition um i can't see that in the
papers anywhere did that relate to the
earlier
um application that was refused perhaps
or was it just missing from the papers
alex come in
um i don't believe i've received a
petition for the current application um
anything been reported to committee
services robert
mr chairman might have the answer
um i i refer because i thought this was
a resubmission
i was referring to the initial um 80
80 strong petition for this against the
for the first one
thank you i thought that might be the
case i i i
councillor pasmo started on the question
of the sewage
um i was actually looking in the
consultees
and i couldn't i couldn't actually see
any of the responses from anglian water
about the
sewage problem it is a is a concern in
so many places
um you did say that it was overflowing
at times uh uh yes it
we uh uh i am on the parish council just
recently gone on and
we have had reports of um of blockages
in the uh sewage system
at the in ixworth road obviously the
concern is that they'd have to dig up
it's worth road and the
and the problems that would cause to the
village and to traffic
um and that's one of our concerns okay
yeah and
so there's there is a problem thank you
chair
alex have you got anything further you
wish to add about uh
what uh they've said anger and water
please
um well nothing further to what uh john
paint mcgee has previously said really
they're
um they're obliged to uh
their actual response where is the copy
of their response
um is is that not in the
that's why i'm asking you right
i couldn't
right i will just check the papers just
a moment
mr chairman yeah may i ask may i answer
the question about my concerns about the
amount of houses on the development
from the country question mr from the
council of richardson
uh yeah yeah thank you thank you very
much thank you thank you for your
indulgence
if um if the committee look at the
original submission
for the 20 houses you'll see that there
was a road running all the way through
which joins onto the back of suffolk
house
and on that application indicative site
plan there is a
um something that says private vehicle
access
what has happened is that suffolk house
have uh renovated a barn or converted a
bomb in the rear of that property which
has no access from this ixworth road
so they require vehicle access from the
horse lane
it is my submission that that is part of
the um
uh the agreement with the applicant and
the landowner well
yeah we've got to be careful we can only
look at what's before us not not
he's on this plan as well if you look at
the plan submitted for this one
it still says private vehicle access
yeah and this won't be a footpath it
will be a road and before your stamp is
dry there will be a further application
yeah that's that that's not relevant to
this
application we can only look at what's
before us today not what may or
may come or may not come in the future
i'm afraid that's the planning reason
is our fear that that is what will
happen that's a reality that's not
relevant
today we can only look at the
application before us i'm afraid okay
um uh cancer turner you had a question
yes thank you chair uh can i just say
cancer sorry i
owe you an apology so i was gonna say at
the start of this that am i right that
the calling notice
was incorrectly labeled in our papers
no uh harry called it in this time but
it's the letter that followed
the calling that was that was from you
so my apologies for that
no no problem just for the record thank
you uh yeah mr cedric
um has the use of horse lane by walkers
and cyclists increased
um since the beginning of the pandemic
you know because it is such a lovely
quiet lane to the nature reserve just
wondering if it
it i don't live that far away i live
quite close and yes
obviously with the pandemic it is it is
well used and
and was noted by the appeals inspector
that he observed it being well used as
well
and it has good reason to be now labeled
a quiet lane and soon to be officially
so
um because it is utilized at all times
and we still have concerns for the
safety of people using that because we
don't believe the pedestrian footpath
will actually do anything because okay i
think i think
that wasn't what the question was it was
increased
i apologize thank you very much
okay uh thank you for now thank you i
now have uh john pemgy who's going to
come in on the housing numbers
he's got that figure for us john i don't
have the figure specifically but can i
just share
i'm just going to do it this way because
i think it's the easiest way to um
kind of draw a line under this for a
second um if i
i'm going to just share my desktop and
to share google because i think it might
be easier just to do that
if you don't mind um yeah i'm hoping
this will work
without showing everything on my desktop
um
that's fine okay see but and i think
it's just easier to be able to look out
at the broader village not just uh the
close-ups that we have and i do
apologize for that
um so this shows various services as you
can see because that's what google does
so we have the salvation army here if
you can see my cursor and there is land
at the back here which
is a proposal for five uh dwellings
there we also then essentially have the
other larger developments of eight which
are dotted along this road i think
there's one here
and there's another one here somewhere
um these were
mostly done through appeal but
essentially there is development that is
coming forward along the road
there are various single infills
um along ashfield road as well
without going away and coming forward
with a proper map
plotting all of the developments uh in
the area
and the individual numbers i can only
offer that there are obviously mostly
low level developments
of uh ones and twos bar conversions and
so on within
the area uh as a whole and the other
earlier on there was mention of what
development is along
this road that leads to first and so if
we just very quickly
uh offer the fact that we go into great
green first and at this point
there are various developments approved
uh in this locality
of course we're moving into the
neighborhood plan area of
first and as well and eventually if you
follow the road
you will get to first and itself
the main center and i think you can see
how rural that is
in in terms of the connection there and
one other
comment just to make sure we mentioned
this this proposal
uh includes obviously a pedestrian link
so the development site is
essentially there and there's a
pedestrian linked through that leads
to the the main road
and the various services there it isn't
entirely reliant
on halls lane and heath road in terms of
the pedestrian
uh flow and i think that just to sort of
clarify
so it cuts through to the effectively
what is the uh
what says norton dog on the map
somewhere around there
yeah so there's the main road yesterday
through effect
so what you're saying is there's not a a
large site of a large number of houses
there are pockets of housing plus the
fives and the and the
uh the five down the salvation army and
some further along
yes unfortunately the system might we
have um doesn't allow us to instantly
put in
tell us all the development in in an
area if you put in norton
and say find me all the dwellings it
tells you everything
that's happened on norton and any any
other location with norton road
in it and unfortunately there's over 258
applications in the last five years
um thank you excuse me chair as soon as
i asked the question
could i just come back and ask about the
access
for the five houses um at the salvation
army are they
directly off the 1088 or are they off
heath road
so the access for the salvation army is
through here i believe
when i remember seeing it which would be
off the a1088
thank you thank you okay i've got
uh robert carmichael you had your hand
up did you want to come in on something
before we go to councillor mayor
just as a very quick brief point i
wouldn't usually speak up and just a
point of clarification as the mention of
a petition came up
was that any petition that is submitted
is for a
application only it does not transfer to
anything that comes
after the first one so i just wanted to
make that clear that it is specific only
to
the reference number as on the petition
thank you chair
thank you okay counselor mayor a
question for mr cedric
well it's a question that's probably
better answered by the the
planning officer um raised by mr cedric
the pedestrian link from the rear of the
site through to exworth road
is listed as a pedestrian link yet
halfway along it
as pointed out by mr cedric it says
private vehicle access
does that mean that that link is
actually a private road
does it mean half of it is a private
road and half of it is a pedestrian link
i think i need clarity about exactly
what that link is
please okay
okay for my chair yeah yes
the application proposes that as a
pedestrian link it's not proposed to be
a new road or a new access onto
express road in the application is it a
pedestrian
link over a private road part of it
i wouldn't say so chair having visited
the site now so the
weather plan says private vehicle access
is that erroneous
can we ignore that um it's confusing
i think there is a point here about um
a certainty of information before us
if i may just bear with me one moment
please
um ultimately
we are of the understanding that's
pedestrian i think for the avoidance of
doubt
if if members are minded to look at this
we would be um it wouldn't be a problem
for us i don't think to ensure
that we condition it to be pedestrian
only
and we can clarify that on that basis
okay
we might be able to ask the applicant
when they come on indeed
just one last final point if i may
chairman um i did earlier on also
measure the
footpath next to the passing bay
the first footpath going up the lane uh
it is one meter wide at that narrow
point that was pointed out by members
earlier
so it's about 1.7 to 1.8 up to the
passing bay
and then it goes around the passing bay
the footpath narrows to one meter
and then it widens again as it continues
up the lane
so i don't know if that helps in terms
of clarification of that point as well
okay thank you um council turner
councilman i'm taking it their old hands
as you've already come in with with
questions yeah okay
right thank you very much thank you mr
cedric thank you for joining us thank
you
thank you very much um we'll now move on
to a supporter of the application mr
stephen bean
you have three minutes to address the
committee
you'd like to turn your camera on please
and your microphone
thank you chairman members of the
committee i have worked in norton for
the last two years and have followed the
progress of the site from the original
application for 20 dwellings
to the current application for nine i've
read the paris council's
submitted comments and listened to the
statements made a few moments ago
i've also spoken to a number of local
residents who remain neutral
or positive about the application but
feel uncomfortable in voicing their
opinions
however norton has a population of just
over 700
and as you have heard 46 letters were
received this equates to six and a half
percent of the village
that have actually written in objecting
to the application is hardly a majority
reading through the 46 letters it
clearly concentrates on the issues
regarding road safety
on both heath road and horse lane no one
is actually objected to the size or
style of the proposed houses
within the inspector's decision on the
previous application for 20
he has made it very clear that he has no
objections to the site
he's also satisfied with the road safety
measures both on the 1088
and heath road again he was satisfied
with the original layout from heath road
to haws lane
however the stretch from the site
heading north to thurston road
originally had no passing places
and the conflict between vehicles and
pedestrians was highlighted as the sole
reason for refusal
the applicant and his agent has clearly
worked closely with the highways
department
to come up with a suitable and safe
scheme that removes the vehicle
pedestrian confrontation
by way of a two metre wide footpath
running the entire length of horse lane
enabling pedestrians to walk safely from
heath road to the existing footpath
network
network without coming into contact with
any vehicles
this along with the inclusion of the
additional four passing places allowing
two vehicles to pass safely
provides a well-thought-out solution to
the planning inspector's comments
all whilst preserving the character and
appearance of the lane
is a thriving village and must continue
to grow and adapt
this is a well thought out scheme
allowing a mixture of homes to attract
families
the proposed dwelling is no doubt to be
built using renewable green incentives
like modern homes require the design has
also incorporated a second
pedestrian walkway giving direct access
to the village hall
children's play area primary school and
public house
if the committee approved the
application it would give rise to a
community infrastructure bill in excess
of 150 000 pounds
which would the paris council would
receive 15 000
not an insignificant amount and this
would be a direct benefit to the village
so in summary natural england the
heritage department
environmental department ecology
department
archaeology officer suffolk fire and
rescue service
all have no objections to the scheme and
finally with the amended design
the highways authority have supported
the application
therefore i urge the committee to follow
the planning office's recommendations
to approve the application thank you
thank you mr bean thank you for that do
we have any questions for mr bean
before we move on nope
okay thank you very much for joining us
uh next we move on to the
agent uh who wishes to speak mr philip
kobold
you have three minutes to address the
committee if you'd like to turn your
camera on
and when you're ready please
thank you mr chairman as you've heard
the previous application to erect 20
dwellings in a larger area was refused
by yourselves
for reasons which stated the development
would cause conflict
between cars and detriment pedestrians
rather to the detriment of highway
safety
and it'd also be detrimental to the
amenity of existing residents
there were no other reasons for refusal
the subsequent appeal was dismissed by
the inspector on two grounds
only firstly that the increased traffic
along hall's lane
would damage the verges because the lane
is too narrow for two cars to pass
and secondly that the development would
lead to conflict between vehicles and
address students using the lane
this new proposal has been the subject
of detailed discussions
with the highway authority who have
specified the sizes of the parking
bays and have also now confirmed that
they are happy with the scheme
and they consider that it addresses
their previous concerns
and those of the inspector clearly the
amount of traffic generated by nine
dwellings will be significantly less
than that which would have been
generated by the
previously proposed 20. secondly the
provision of the fort work footways to
the north and south
will ensure that there is no conflict
between pedestrian vehicular traffic
as you've heard the footway to the south
can be provided within highway land
the footwear to the north will be
provided on third party land
for which the owner has given their
approval thirdly the provision of four
passing bays to the north of the site
and one to the south will enable two
vehicles to pass
without damaging the verges the highway
authority has confirmed that these
passing bays can all be provided
within highway land the pedestrian link
from the site to exodus road was also
included
as part of the previous scheme for 20
dwellings this will provide a more
direct and convenient link to the
village centre
without the need for residents to walk
along heath road which does not have a
public footpath
the public house primary school
preschool village shop and village hall
are all within a short walk of the site
inspector stated previously and i quote
the new pedestrian link between the site
and the village
will give people a safe access to the
services in the village
and public transport and as mr scott
said earlier
it's much safer than trying to cross the
a-1088 at the crossroads
and with regards to the junction of
haw's lane with heath road the inspector
also stated
it is common in villages to have
junctions that do not meet modern
standards
but i see no issue in its ability to
safely accommodate the additional
traffic generated
and again that was on the basis of
twenty not nine dwellings as proposed
council can ensure that the highway
improvements are undertaken by the
grampian style condition
and the works within the highway will
also need to be the subject of a section
278 agreement with a highway authority
so there are mechanisms to ensure that
those works are provided
in summary this proposal addresses the
previous concerns expressed by the
council
and the inspector it represents
sustainable development and will provide
economic social
and environmental benefits for the
village thank you thank you very much
and time was just up so good good timing
thank you
okay do we have any questions at all for
the agent
yes council eben
morning thank you for that um could you
um advise us whether this site
is was put forward as part of um
the emerging joint local plan from mid
african baby thank you
no i don't think it was submitted as a
land allocation but it has been the
subject of
positive pre-application discussions um
and those
initial discussions were about three
years ago
okay because our our papers say it has
had no
pre-app advice so but but it wasn't
put forward for the joint local plan
thanks very much and just to be clear
the current application this submission
for nine
was not the subject of a pre-application
inquiry
but the previous scheme for 20 was thank
you
casa matheson
thank you chair can you clarify this
this matter of
self-build properties that the parish
council has has mentioned
in its in its submission its objections
um
have you been you know marketing this
site
um or is it the intention to market this
site specifically for
self build no there's been no marketing
of the site and
and that wouldn't normally take place
until permission had been granted if
permission is granted
but this proposal as mr payment g said
is for
market housing not for self builds
all right thank you thank you could you
just give us any clarification around
the footpath and the
and the the access that was mentioned
earlier by where we've got you on
yes sorry chairman that that is a
drafting error because that
original private vehicle access was
noted on the plan
for 20 that should have cut that
shouldn't be on there on this
scheme for nine that link from the edge
of the turning head through to ixford
road
that'll be a pedestrian link only thank
you for clearing that up
uh councillor mayor
thank you chief um mr cobble
am i right in assuming i think you said
the footpath the two meter footpath
running up horse lane to the north
that is not on council highways land
that is on
a private owners land and they've given
permission for that path is that what
you said
yes not not all of that is achievable
within highway land
so the but the land owner has given
their agreement
for that footpath to be provided and the
landowner was
notified of the application and the
relevant certificate
was completed as part of the application
okay thank you
thank you very much any other questions
at all
nope okay thank you very much for
joining us thank you
okay so i'd now like to turn to the ward
members
now we have two ward members councillor
turner you
you um i'm sorry i wasn't because you
put something in writing i thought i was
going to be reading that out
but actually you're here so i'm guess
you that we don't
we can uh that's just a supplementary uh
speech that you've sent in yes that that
was
um sent ages ago when this application
was
submitted so yeah okay so over to you
yep
okay um yes i'm wendy turner council
wendy turner
uh thurston for thurston ward i'm
objecting to this application for three
main reasons
pedestrian safety pollution and loss of
biodiversity
firstly i support the parish council in
their concern for road users which
include pedestrians cyclists and
motorists
horse lane is narrow and despite the
added passing places i feel this road
would still pose a danger to the stated
road users
this reason was also expressed by the
inspector at a previous
appeal the inspectors stated that the
danger from traffic which is currently
experienced by pedestrians in the rural
part of the lane would increase should
the proposed development go ahead
a previous application on the same site
for 20 houses was rejected by the
planning committee for the same reasons
i quote the proposed development
accessing horse lane would if approved
likely result in significant conflict
between cars and pedestrians by
construction traffic
and during the lifetime of the
development and given the design and
character of the lane
would be detrimental to highway safety
and amenity for existing residents
moreover the school village hall
recycling center and the children's
player are located on the opposite side
of the a1088
a busy and dangerous road as stated in
the parish council's report
children would be negotiating this road
to get to school and to the play
facilities
currently there is no electronic
pedestrian crossing
my second reason for objecting to this
application would be the added pollution
caused by the extra vehicle movements
there is evidence that air quality is
significantly impacted by pollution
caused by brake
tyre and road surface dust higher levels
of braking will be required as cars will
need to be continually pulling into the
passing places
stopping and starting and idling their
cars it has been proven that idling
produces harmful co2
emissions particularly harmful for
children and asthma sufferers
so much so in fact that doctors have set
up their own campaign group to try and
reduce idling and
diesel pollution thirdly the development
is outside the settlement boundary and
will be building in the countryside
bearing in mind that the government and
our own council have declared a
biodiversity in climate emergency it is
imperatively
aimed to build these boundaries to
preserve the countryside and current
biodiversity
even though this site hasn't been
classed as significant it is still
significant and that we are losing
biodiversity at an alarming rate
the state of nature reports stated in
2019 that 41
of uk species studies have declined
since 1970
the ecology report has stated that
biodiversity mitigation
measures will need to be implemented but
this will not help the bats birds
hedgehogs and vertebrates that will be
displaced during construction
some of these species may not survive or
return after their homes have been
destroyed
it is for these three reasons highway
safety increased pollution and
biodiversity loss i
urge the committee to refuse this
application
thank you chair thanks very much do we
have any i tell you what we'll do we'll
have both ward members then we'll take
questions for both world members
together so
cancer richardson over to you
thank you very much chair um i've got
three sort of main points i'd like to
talk about and there were some
questions during after the office's
report from some of the committee
members which i think i can try and
weave some of the answers in into my
comments as well so the three main areas
i want to talk about
first um highways second is the
character and appearance of horse lane
and then thirdly the suitability of the
site itself
so highways i think as you've probably
heard is the largest and most
contentious issue in this development
um from my perspective and i think this
was a question that was raised about
um hgvs and uh cars passing one another
within
4.1 metres i think that would be
especially difficult it's not just htvs
it could also be
any of the emergency service vehicles or
we'd hope that doesn't happen very
regularly um but there's also the the
more frequent possibility of a
conflict between an oncoming car and one
of our refuse lorries for example
and i'm particularly worried about where
that footpath narrows to just one meter
because if there was a large vehicle and
a car in conflict then one of them would
ultimately have to go on to that
pavement and should there be a
vulnerable user
um on that pavement at the time i think
that would present
um unacceptable degree of harm just that
possibility alone
and just to if i can also talk about the
wider context i think
as council turner's already said all of
the amenities that you would look to
access within norton
are on the eastern edge of the a1088 the
1888 itself is a very busy a road
it connects um thetford and exworth to
the north
through to the a14 so it is a primary
access point for several villages to get
to the dual carriageway so i think it's
an important consideration that you'll
be trying to cross that road
from the point at which that pavement or
that footpath emerges
um across the busy area where there is
no island there's no zebra crossing
there's there's no safe means of
of um crossing that particular road and
so that's i think a
important consideration when you look at
the wider context
similarly when we consider where horse
lane um to the north meets with
thurston road that particular stretch of
road is a
60 mile an hour speed limit and i can't
see anything in the reports that says
what assessment of the visibility
displays have been done at that
particular junction
because i know immediately to the left
there's a large
um degree of hedges which do limit
visibility to some extent so i'm
particularly worried about that access
point
um and as councilor matheson said that
road although it's relatively rural
towards the eastern end of thurston it's
there's about 400 new houses being built
there
and thurston road connecting to the 1888
will be the primary access point
for most of those um vehicles coming
from those sites so i think that is an
important consideration when you look at
the overall
question of highway safety um talking
about character and appearance
um this was something that the appeal
inspector did actually talk about
uh he said that there would be an
unacceptable degree of harm to the
character and appearance of
horse lane as a rural um area and quoted
policies gp1 and
t10 um in an objecting um
or sorry in upholding the committee's
original decision and i think that's
from what i can see there's nothing in
this new
um subsequent application that in any
way changes the issues that the
um appeals inspector identified and
there's also i think
councillor field talked about the
question of density
and i completely understand where he's
coming from with that um if we just i
appreciate obviously this is entirely
indicative because
anything to do with layout and design
will be done or dealt with that reserve
matters
but just looking at the the indicative
site layout you've got several dwellings
there
a um c and f where they've got the
stacked parking that we don't like to
see and obviously i appreciate that's
purely indicative
but at this looking at the um overall
density of the site i don't think you
could achieve nine dwellings in that
area without doing anything different
um likewise i think this slightly
disappointing degree of um
open green space within the application
beyond what's private residential
gardens
and again i don't think anything more
than that could be delivered within
within the density that we're looking at
and then finally the last one i want to
make is about the suitability of the
site itself and i'm afraid i have to
correct what
mr kobold said this application sorry
this site was put forward as part of the
jlp
and it was considered within our sheila
and i've got the reference number it's
ss0387 and it was dismissed on the basis
that it had no possibility of creating
suitable access to the site
so for that reason it was subsequently
discounted from the jlp and as council
turner's already said it's outside the
settlement boundary and the existing
built-up area
now obviously i having been on the
planning committee before i know it's
quite difficult when you as the
committee members
have to make a judgment when the
highways offer no objections and
the officer's recommendation is for um
approval but when i
what i would just emphasize is when
you're weighing up the benefits versus
the
harm within this site i just want to
talk about two main things quickly one
is the fact that as you've heard
this is for nine dwelling so it falls
below the threshold of 10
by which we would accumulate affordable
housing and in terms of mid-suffolk's
overall housing supply position
in the last report that we've got is
from october where our five-year housing
land supply requirement is 2809 units
and we've currently got outstanding 4310
a surplus in excess of 1500 giving us
a 7.67 year land supply
so from the wider communities benefits i
can see very little
um we've got enough housing in
mid-suffolk um according to our own
stated position
we've got no affordable housing within
this particular scheme um we've
dismissed it ourselves as part of the
jlp we've deemed it not to be suitable
and there's always the um highways and
other concerns that have been raised
which i
in my argument um would be grants for
refusal on that basis but i'm
happy to answer any questions if there
are any chair thank you thank you very
much
okay happy to take any questions for the
ward members
are there any yeah councillor muller
yeah yes thank you chair um
councillor richardson um thank you very
much for your statement that was great
um we've heard that there's been an
increased use of walk walkers and
cyclists
along hall's lane can you give me an
approximate um
number of how many vehicles normally use
this particular lane during the day
please
that's a very good question i don't know
personally but i do know it does get
used occasionally
by people using it to avoid the a1088 to
join with thurston road
and i think that's my concern is that at
the moment it's a very rural lane
and with some of the increasing
development elsewhere it may see
increased usage and obviously this would
then encourage it if it's
it's deemed to be um accessible to other
vehicles
thank you very much
thank you yes i i did ask earlier um
if we might explore a little more um
what the um reality was of the local bus
network um there was an awful lot of
points made by the two world members i'm
not sure we heard much about that no
you're quite right councilman
that was on my list of things to pick up
but i completely forgot so i apologize
for that
yes i for the frequency of the bus
service in norton is quite good
um with several buses per day but where
the two bus stops are in this part of
norton
the sort of the northernmost one is
almost i think directly opposite where
the footpath emerges
onto the 1888 but it's on the opposite
side of the road so you need to cross
the road in order to access the bus
service
and the second one to the south is on
the same side of the road
on the 1888 but you'd have to cross the
junction um at the crossroads in order
to access that so there's
my sort of argument would be that
there's access issues and connectivity
issues with with
accessing the local bus service regular
though it is
thank you thank you okay any other
questions
nope okay members well we've had all the
information put before us
it's now to open up to debate and to
discuss
and to reach a conclusion so over to you
counselor matheson and counselor field
yes yeah just just to point
out we we do tend to take um take a
break around this
um time but we've had a good old day and
a half go at it
and um i think i think we'll have a
break between the two applications is my
plan
okay if you you hope we'll get this one
done quickly
oh we don't have to get it done quickly
but i mean it i mean we've got 20 you
know
are you are you i mean if you're if you
were very keen to have a break now i'm
happy to have a break but i
i was planning to take one about 20 25
whenever we're done with this
unless anyone feels very strong keep
going chairman
keep going yeah councillor field
gear off
okay sort of conventional to say these
things are always difficult
i i find really the
the impact on the rural nature of horse
lane
uh concerns me a great deal
we have had an inspector who says
there's conflict with cars and
pedestrians which there obviously is
it will increase as we put nine more
houses in a village of 500 it won't
increase that dramatically but it
clearly found it an issue
and something we shouldn't uh enhance um
i am concerned about the solution that
we've obtained which places
passing places which i'm inclined to
agree with
um passing places that will allow two
cars to pass but clearly not to hgvs
the probability of getting two hdvs down
there simultaneously is pretty low
um a very wide footpath which really
urbanizes the line tremendously it's a
it's a quiet lane and it turns it into a
a sort of an urban walkway so i find
those
uh issues also the issue of the
um upgrade to the sewage system which is
sort of
we're told will be uh necessary but as a
completely undefined date
so there's a there is a wider issue with
with the
increased load on a system which
currently apparently can't cope
however i do wonder to what extent i'm
reacting to the sort of excited
generation of every problem we can
possibly think of to oppose
some of these schemes we make villages
sound like horrendously dangerous places
to live
with the incredible problem of having to
cross a road i think i was taught out
across the road when i was about
five um we do over
emphasize those things but having said
that it really
leaves the core issues
still there you know the the the
urbanization of a
rural area for a matter of
nearly nine houses um
there is an impact on biodiversity as
well i'm afraid unfortunately there are
too many
human beings on the planet and to some
extent
you know there will be such a an impact
whatever we do and wherever we build
those nine houses
and although kovid is killing off some
of those of my age
i'm not sure it's doing enough to make a
big impact on the problem
so i think overall that's a quite a long
ramble to say i really feel at the
moment
that i'm still against this although
we've addressed
the problem of the um
the conflict between pedestrians and
vehicles we haven't really addressed the
problem of the
the impact on the nature of this rural
area
so i'm against okay
absolutely rejection
okay you want to come in very quickly
before we've heard anyone else
i'll wait for other people if you like
it's your decision
it's i don't want to be influencing the
committee if you want to
would you like to propose it a refusal
or not
i'll post a refusal okay
thank you and next is counselor eben
uh thank you very much chair um
councillor field was um just diplomatic
in calling this difficult
um i would be less diplomatic and
sailing's a nightmare
um i i just think this is wholly
unsuitable for development
um in her currently in horse lane the
six
houses um and this had more than double
the housing and while you know six to 15
doesn't sound a lot on that on that tiny
lane and how can we
propose a lane to be a quiet lane and
then turn it into
a virtual urban environment with um
more traffic passing places footpaths
and so on
um so you know that's a big issue
um there's a big issue about pedestrian
safety um we're going
walking straight out onto the a 1088 i
mean that's a really busy road it
takes arctic lorries um to and fro
between
towards um thetford um
and exworth and thetford and
expecting i certainly wouldn't want
young children to be going down that
pedestrian path
and then barreling straight out onto the
um
1088 i mean that's an accident waiting
to happen
and i agree that the visibility i know
not reasonably well i think the
visibility there for testings is very
poor
um the access to the main village all
the services are across the other side
of the road it's the wrong side
of the crossroads for development
it needs to be on the same you know the
development if there is any should be on
the side of the road where the
pub is where the school is where the
playing field is where the preschool is
it's um it's just not in the right
location
um it's outside the settlement boundary
there's the issues with anglia water and
the sewer supplies and i know
full well with issues in my own village
that those things do not get sorted
we are talking six years plus for
angular water to
to move on these issues um
i could go on but i'm aware other people
want to speak
so i just think it is very poor
sight um i'm very disappointed that the
only changes from the
um uh dismissal at the appeal
was to add in another couple of parking
spaces but how we can suggest
that a two meter virtual two meter
wide road is suitable for for traffic um
delivery vans um waste vehicles and so
on i've
i do find that um very odd um it's
almost as though we feel we've got to
approve this for some reason
so i i am against this but um i will
um be waiting to hear from my uh
fellow colleagues to see what they say
um before potentially
um anything further thank you very much
chair thank you councilman i just remind
council phil that as you have proposed
refusal you will need to give the
reasons
and uh why as we obviously after
everyone has spoken so
if you just want to gather those
thoughts uh counselor
mansell you're next uh thank you chair
um i
i am reasonably familiar with norton
um and this particular um road
and um area of of the village
uh first of all i would like to just
dispute councillor richardson's comment
about a regular bus service through
norton
i've just looked at the timetable there
are three buses in one direction
four in the other uh monday to friday
between berry and stone market i don't
think i'd really call that a good bus
service but that's
maybe that's a personal opinion um on
the subject
of the rural nature of horse lane it is
currently an extremely
rural road usually having grass down the
middle of it
uh it's a regular part of my regular
cycle route if i'm going towards bury
um uh councillor richardson did mention
the poor visibility where horse lane
meets
um thurston road and i agree with him
there there is a tree
if you're looking back toward to the
you're coming up up horse lane
and you're looking to the right um there
is a tree it's quite hard to see
carl's coming if you look the other way
there is a humpback bridge
and a slight bend in the road it isn't
good visibility
um and i agree with much of what
councillor field said
about the rural nature of horselane
being
completely eroded which was one of the
comments by the inspector in the
previous appeal case
um although the the inspector was really
talking about
um vehicles uh mounting the verge and
wearing it away i
i think the addition of a two meter wide
concrete
footpath um and some passing places will
make it look like an
urban street not a rural lane i mean
bearing in mind that this
this uh particular road um on an os
map has uh dotted edges and it's not
even colored yellow
you know it really is a lane it's not
even what i would call a yellow road
um but by by far my biggest concern
with this particular application is um
the uh footpath that deposits people
right on the edge of the 1088 um i think
this is one of the major issues in
norton is the fact that there is no
safe crossing of the a-road through the
center of the village
and i think any further development on
this side of the a-1088
um there needs to be some provision of a
safe uh crossing point
a uh whatever it was called what they
call it an uncontrolled pedestrian
crossing point
with not even a traffic island i think
is just
too poor i think the least we can ask
any developer
is to provide some safe point to cross
that road
we keep hearing time and time again all
the facilities are on the east side of
the 1088
so putting houses here uh people still
have to cross the road
and i'm sorry i disagree with the
planning officer i don't think the
visibility there is good
there's a slight bend in the road there
is a lot of traffic
um along the 1088 and it is it is
completely unsatisfactory
not to allow uh have a put a safe um
a safe pedestrian crossing on on the
1088.
um the other big issue i've got with
development in norton
is as we heard from the planning officer
he said there's mostly low level
development
we have a vast number of small
little five to eight house developments
or or even smaller than that
uh through scattered throughout norton
none of which
provide affordable housing because
they're all below the threshold
very few of them even provide small
market houses
they're nearly all four and five-bedroom
houses
and i think if you look up the average
house price in norton it is well above
the average for the area
because there are such a dearth can i
just say i think we've got to be careful
council members we've got to keep to you
know the price
price of house prices is not relevant to
this committee and
you are and we're rambling by talking
about that could i ask you to keep
the house excuse me could you just stop
one sec could i ask you to keep to
relevant facts
we've got a lot of people that want to
speak price of house pricing is not
really not necessarily house prices but
i just think that
the nine houses here they are likely to
all be large houses and i don't think
that is what norton needs
um sorry you've you've disrupted my my
flow and i can't remember what the other
thing i wanted to say was
um but um i i really don't think i can
support
this application thank you councillor
um thank you very much matthew um i do
i have a lot of sympathy and i agree
with a lot of what john fields says
my biggest concern is the um
impact on the lane and passing places
and we all know you get to the winter
time and so on and
cars go up in the virgin it makes one or
potentially
could make a real mess and i haven't
decided which way to vote on this yet on
one of this in the rest of the debate
i'm not against housing per se i want to
make that clear it's an outline
application
um but i do think it's the impact on the
visual environment particularly in the
highways link and i mentioned the sewage
i know it can be dealt with
by statutory provision um i just want to
hear what others say but
i'm at the moment leaning to um towards
refusal
but i do want to make it clear i'm not
against um development per se people
need houses to live in
thank you very much thank you councillor
thank you chair um looking at my notes
in front of me i
i'm in danger of repeating much of
what's already been said but i think
um i need to do so i actually visited
this lane
and i'm shocked how narrow it was um
there is
soil and grass running up the middle of
it it is a rural lane
and actually one of very few rural lanes
that we still retain in suffer
in that many of our roads are now being
um
suffering from increased traffic and so
i think
it is true that that lane defined the
area defines the area's character and
appearance
and the passing places well they will
improve
um safety though it is interesting to
know that's a 60 mile an hour
lane you know it the use of a passing
place when someone's coming at you at
that speed would be
um frankly frightening um is safety
improved
yes it is but then the points regarding
the footpath of the 1088
children running out on that foot
footpath there's no
there's no barrier no footpath straight
onto the road that's
concerning but what we're doing we're
urbanizing
our lovely suffolk countryside and i'd
yeah i i have no trouble in supporting
um the proposal made by
councillor field thank you there you
have does that mean you're seconding or
yes just
yeah you're second okay thank you
councillor matheson
yes i um i shall be speaking at great
length at all um
members have made lots of lots of good
points
in common sense terms one looks at this
uh location and and say well
it's just not a suitable place to
develop
um it does not have the access and and
as it
happened that the um planning policy
when they were looking at um
allocations um they also felt that and
we know that has limited weight
so i just want to to put very succinctly
that the the the footpaths and the
passing bays and all the rest of it
will impact the character of the
rural lane severely severely
not a bit but a lot and
the we haven't actually mentioned
recently but
there is the point at 5.7 that we are we
are being offered substandard visibility
um at the junction between heath road
and horse lane
which is which is not great um you know
do we do we need to have another
substandard access visibility
not really but i did want to come back
to the
um the chair didn't really like me to
explore in this point but
when we've been looking at the big
applications in in
thurston and elmswell and in this case
the thurston one is more relevant
we we've been told that the the the the
large additional amount of
traffic traffic that's inevitably going
to be generated will find its way around
by
various means to get to where it's at
the to the main roads of the a14 or the
a143
and so it does seem to me that some of
that
extra traffic is going to find its way
firstly
along the the thirst and norton road
um and come out onto the 1088 but if
that starts to pile up a little bit
some genius is going to think i know
i'll pop through horse lane that's a
good cut through
and and that is that is not
not good at all so i think that is the
the other problem that i particularly
have apart from ones that members have
have addressed so um yeah i i think we
we have to sometimes
um pull together
a balance of minor disadvantages and say
where can we see the benefits of this
compared to this assortment of
individually not major but minor
um disadvantages so so it's overall no
thank you very much um i have muller
next
thank you chair um i've listened with
interest to um the debate
today and i must concur with what my
colleagues have actually said
and i'm afraid in this instance i cannot
support this application so i'll be
voting
um with the um propose in the second
against the actual actual proposal on
this one thank you
thank you so everyone's spoken as one to
speak i'll just
add my pen is worth before we go back to
councillor field uh and councillor mayor
for uh reasons for refusal
um uh so so to me i guess the crux of it
is
looking at the appeal decision that was
reached last time and where we're at
today
has enough moved substantially enough to
to move it forward and to take
how much weight do we give that appeal
decision versus what's before us today
and i think we're all battling with the
same thing actually that
there isn't enough of a change now if
we've got it horribly wrong
and i've missed something well then i'm
sure
you know there is an appeals process
which obviously the acting can go down
again
but looking at it raw from where i sit
there there just are too many
things that do not stack up uh that
allow me to support the application and
we've heard all the reasons why so i
won't go through them again
so i i likewise will be uh supporting
council field and councillor mayor
in their uh proposal and seconding so
councillor field
um can i go back to you we have um john
paintman g has been listening to the
reasons
uh for possible refusal can i ask him
maybe just to give a summary
uh and then come to you and see if
there's anything else you want to add to
it
or you feel we've missed are you happy
if we take that approach i'm happy to do
that i've
i've been searching through the
inspector's report
and looking at his main conclusions and
uh have some feelings around there but
i'm quite very happy for john palmer
john can i go over to you please john
indeed um
so this is this is an interesting one
because of the material consideration of
the appeal
and then you're looking at what the
differences are um
i think from what i've heard um
the the main points well let me let me
cover
one point that i think we need to be
careful of first and i i just want to
avoid it if possible and i'll tell you
why in my professional opinion
um firstly there has been a great
mention of the a108
um and essentially members have been
discussing the
accessibility of services uh within the
village
and the need to cross that main road
now i i take the point that you you
could have a consideration
of the highway risk of uh crossing
uh that road at the point where the
proposed pedestrian link comes out but
that
same pedestrian link was part of the 20
house proposal in the appeal
and at no point in that appeal that i've
read and i will be
corrected if i'm wrong was there any
real concern raised by the inspector
in respect of that pedestrian link to
the a
108.8 i would advise members not
to refuse this application on that basis
given that material consideration
as i think that would represent a risk
uh to the council
and in terms of being defendable um
moving on though i have listened to the
issues
uh of hall's lane itself and i think
essentially what you're saying is
you feel that essentially the reason for
refusal last time for 20 houses
still essentially applies today for the
nine
um although it has evolved slightly in
the conversations of the debate
i would suggest that what you're also
saying now is not only is it the impact
of the development
in terms of the highway impacts on on
the lane and the character of the lane
but there is a degree of urbanization
due to the required
mitigation works of highway improvements
in itself
while helping towards safety
has a detriment in terms of character
so maybe i could suggest i will try and
suggest
this so i've essentially taken the
previous reason
refusal and just adapted it slightly and
if you're if you bear with me i'll
read this out and see if this kind of
fits what the members have been debating
so i'm now saying
notwithstanding the highway improvements
proposed
the proposed development accessing horse
lane would
if approved likely result in significant
conflict between cars and pedestrians
by construction traffic and during the
lifetime of the development
given the design and character of the
lane that would be detrimental to
highway safety
and amenity for existing and future
residents
furthermore wear and tear as well as the
highways improvements proposed
would be visually detriment detrimental
sorry to the
character of the rural lane due to the
increased traffic
including cars and larger vehicles and
the urbanization
of
sections 12 and paragraphs 108
and 110. would that help
cancer field yes i think that sounds
reasonable i certainly looked to the
inspectors conclusions and came to
come to the view that the the uh the
first the paragraph
26 is conclusions on the main issue
26 has not been resolved it's really
been made worse
by the um urbanization of this lane
which is is the point that john
payman jr just mentioned um
i i i certainly think they have made
movements on the highway safety issue
so i don't want to emphasize that too
much but it's really the
urbanization the impact on immunity of
the uh
the people in general in the village
really that
removes this very pleasant rural area
for them and
changes it dramatically so yes i think
that i'll go along with the professional
view
thank you and council mayor are you
happy with the uh
proposals that's been read out yeah
thank you before we go to a vote on that
we have council matheson you have your
hand up
yes i i wanted to ask officers and the
um possibly the legal adviser
um to what extent are we constrained to
to the to the reasons for refusal in the
appeal
um and apart from i think the one
obvious thing
that is that we can object to the
anew is the is the change to the
character
of the lane resulting from from the the
passing places and the
and the footpath that were not there
before but um
i mean are we constrained in that way or
are we not um no i mean if you want me
to
come in yes please yeah well i mean
as a matter of law a planning
inspector's decision is not a
binding precedent in the same way that a
high court or a court of appeal judgment
would be
however it it has been commonly
recognized it's a material consideration
it's something that the council should
take note of
read with a degree of respect and so
forth but that
and and be mindful that a a later
planning inspector will do likewise
that that's i think that's unless one of
my planet colleagues wants to add
anything so that that's the best advice
i can give
yeah i think i mean
john is there any particular point you
wanted to raise is that why you asked
that or were we happy to you well
i was
my contribution you know i did point out
that the you know there were a lot
a lot of individually minor issues here
and i wondered whether um whether
officers
felt cumulative impacting one or two
more in or not
um i mean the safety issues being raised
and the uh john can you just be very
specific what points you want you're
talking about bringing in
um i think the
you know the issue of crossing the 1088
it is a major trunk road
okay so yeah we know that so the
crossing the dangers of the 1078 what
what's the other key points then we'll
go back to the
uh we'll go back to drum paper
very specifically well yeah we're not
allowed to
talk about the lack of need but but
there is and the housing
need that it doesn't match up with not
just i just want something
yeah i think probably the other one
really would be the um
the poor sustainable transport really
okay thank you the local bus network is
okay sustainable transport thank you
i've made a note of those two i think
councilman so you may have one you want
to track in
the pot uh no i was just going to say
that um i i i remember raising the
crossing of the 1088 when this came to
committee before
and i suspect it was dismissed and we
were told we weren't allowed to to add
that because highways hadn't commented
on it
and that may well have been one of part
of the reason why the inspector didn't
mention it because we didn't mention it
in our reasons for refusal
for the previous one if we're not
legally bound to
to have the same reasons for refusal i i
i'm i'd be happy to go along with the
council matthison's suggestion that we
we do mention it because i think it is a
major issue
thank you okay so i'll go back to
councillor field councillor mayor and to
john pateman g
john can you just clarify is that
something we can throw in then if we can
i'll ask john and
uh um okay the answer is
the answer is you can my
recommendation would be that you don't
and
i would ultimately it comes down to what
is reasonable
and we have if we if we seem to be
unreasonable we would subject ourselves
to cost potentially
appeal now we
in terms of reasonableness we did not
have this issue
with the appeal before we don't have a
highways backing
for this issue either um
it is not what i would propose to you to
be a robustly defendable point
however that this is your debate and
this is your committee i i'm
you know i'm merely your guide okay i'm
going to get back to
councillor field and counselor mayor how
do you want to play are you happy with
what we've got or did you want to add
anything further
i i think i'm happy with what we've got
i
would rather not invoke um
the danger of classing a road which is
is a minor increase on a danger which
already exists for a vast
percentage of population council i'll
not do that
thank you councillor mayor you happy we
stay as we are
yes indeed i think we should take uh
okay
so on that basis we're now going to go
to a vote
um on the reasons that have been read
out but what we will do
is uh i will now um uh ask the chief
planning well the chief planning officer
has read out the proposal before us
um but i will now ask the uh governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
and just
confirm uh those points to us
yeah um so the recommendation has read
out by
the proposal sorry as read out by mr
payment i've copied this
into your vote so if any members do wish
to read it again before they vote it is
available
there um so what i will do chairs if you
are content i will start the vote
yes please thank you chair so if members
could please go to the modern.gov app
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner for today's agenda
there you'll see the subsection of
attendance voting and if you please
please click on that it will take you to
today's votes
in there you will see that in progress
is our vote in a light blue color
and if you vote for you're voting for
refusal
against your voting against refusal just
to be clear
[Applause]
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and i can confirm that the
result
is that there are seven votes four and
one against so the motion of refusal is
carried
okay thank you very much okay so it's
now
seven sorry seven 11 38
can i propose we start again at 11 50
sharp so 12 minute break
uh 11 50. uh we start again for the
final application before us
that's the cocking in the street in
brantford see you in 10 minutes thank
you
0-586 [ __ ] in the street bran for nast
the case of us samantha summers to
introduce the application to committee
over to you good morning everyone uh
just checking to make sure that you can
see my presentation
yeah we can lovely okay i'll just
change my um pointer so that we can see
that
red dot as well
um item 7b can be found on page 79 of
your agendas
the application seeks full planning
permission for the erection of a
detached single-story dwelling
in part of the beer garden of the cockin
the street branford
the application comes to committee as it
is considered to be controversial
there have been a total of 155
objections
from 137 separate households
there's been one letter of support the
parish councils of brantford and
sprawton have objected
and highways have raised concerns over
visibility slaves
the application site is shown in the
hatched area
this is branford village and the caulkin
is located at the southern end
of the main road through the village in
this area here
[Music]
this is the site location plan the red
line is the application site and shows
the access to the highway through the
car park
the blue line shows the extent of the
inn's ownership which includes
the inn
car park
and beer garden in the southern part of
the site
there are a few constraints to this site
as it is in the center
of a village
with a primary school field to the west
and residential properties to the north
east and south of the site
the street is a mix of residential and
business properties
the street is a very busy road and many
cars park along the road
in this 30 mile an hour speed limit area
the kokkin is a grade 2 listed building
and the buildings opposite are also
grade two listed
branford is classed as a key service
center in the core
strategy
the application has been received as a
resubmission
of a previously refused scheme for the
erection of two
two-story dwellings on the same site
at the back of the beer garden here
sorry we seem to be having a problem
with my cursor moving on to the next
slide there we go
the application was refused on heritage
impact
and highway safety the bottom drawing
shows the refused dwellings sitting
behind the cockin
with a ridge height that exceeds the
[ __ ] which is a modest one and a half
story building so just in this shaded
part here that was the proposed
two-story dwellings
this is the proposed layout of the site
the axis would remain
unchanged and would access through the
car park
here
there would be a reduction in the number
of parking spaces for the public house
from 23 to 20 of the customers
and two proposed parking spaces
uh for the proposed dwelling
uh there are also two disabled uh
parking spaces for the cork in
the uh proposed parking area for the
dwelling would be
in a different colored surfacing uh
which would be
a resin bound gravel just to delineate
uh the difference between customer
parking and the residential parking
areas
the dwelling would be single story
concerns have been raised over the
residential amenity of the future
occupants of the dwelling as they could
be impacted by activities in the beer
garden
the building has been designed to
provide
a private amenity space in a courtyard
situation just here which would protect
it from
uh noise within the beer garden
a brick wall is also proposed along this
eastern boundary
with a hedge planted within the beer
garden
this would also help with noise impact
and also privacy
issues concerning the private use of the
garden
it is noted that some backland
development has already been
allowed on the street with this newly
built
property to the north of the site
there is some evidence on historic maps
that the application site
formed a kitchen garden without
buildings
it is likely that these would have been
functionally associated with the inn
and removed in the early 20th century
during pre-application discussions it
was suggested that any proposed dwelling
should reflect a
low-key simple building with materials
and designs that could be
read as subservient to the inn the
proposed dwelling
is single story with slate roof and
timber cladding above
a brick plinth windows and doors would
be timber
the heritage team have identified no
harm to the setting of the listed
buildings
from this proposal
the dwelling would be a modest
three-bedroom property and would conform
to current nationally described space
standards
at 86 metres square for a single
dwelling
with three bedrooms only one window is
proposed on the side
of the dwelling which shares a boundary
with the beer garden
this would serve as a bathroom
the street city shows the low level of
the roof against that of being
in terms of landscaping the existing
trees and hedgerows
are to be retained there is one section
of trees which are to be removed
and replaced with hedging in this area
just here
additional planting would be
proposed along the boundary wall
low-level shrubs are proposed at the
front of the dwelling
many of the objections raised relate to
the loss of the beer garden
which of course is an issue of great
interest at the present time
this has been carefully considered and
it is felt that the remaining space is
sufficient for the inn to continue to
trade effectively
so this area here which um is
a bit sunburned by the looks of it uh is
where the proposed uh dwelling would be
the remaining
area here um would still be retained as
beer garden
uh there is a pool area
just in this section here um and a patio
just here and a children's play area the
rest of the garden would just be laid to
grasp as it is already
the inn also benefits from a large sun
room that functions as a dining room
which is to the side of the inn
it is understood that village events
have been held in the beer garden
previously
however this has been subject to the
agreement of the landlords
and would be subject to that agreement
for future events
it is noted that branford has two larger
green
areas in which
local events could be held and these
include the garden to the rear of the
village hall
and also the millennium field near to
the river gipping
a slightly different angle of the site
showing the extent of the beer garden
and the application site so again we're
looking at the application site
being in this rear part here and the
rest of the garden being retained for
the pub's use
just another view of it just to give you
some context of the space that would
still be available
which would be more than half of the
existing
moving on to some photographs this is
the front of the inn with the access on
the right hand side
this is looking left from the access
towards the center of the village
highways have raised concerns about
visibility displays
there is no intensification of the use
of the access proposed by the
development and therefore it is felt
that it would be unreasonable to object
on highway safety grounds
the traffic assessment accompanied the
application and previous concerns have
been dealt with
a lamppost and telegraph pole are both
within the line of sight
just here
um there are parked cars along this area
here
which does tend to slow traffic uh
coming along the road
this is looking right when leaving the
car park the listed building protrudes
slightly
into the visibility display it is noted
that both
the bend just here and also the parked
cars further towards the center of the
village
do slow traffic coming along the street
this is the front of the inn and the
sunroom which is used for dining
this is the side garden which has the
bull area
which is shown in the sandy part just
here
and also the children's play area the
proposed dwelling would be
to the rear of the site just along this
tree line here
this is looking through the garden uh to
the application site at the back here
and you would see the brick wall and the
hedging from the front here
this is the bull area which doesn't
appear to be used for that purpose
anymore
it has two pergolas which can form
sheltered seating areas
uh moving into the car park area this is
the rear of the inn
and the disabled parking can be seen
just in this area here
this is uh the access point with the
listed buildings
just in this area here
so this is moving along to the rear of
the
beer garden and this is where the
proposed dwelling would sit
uh the hedges to be retained along the
boundary with the primary school field
and these are the trees that are
proposed to be removed and replaced with
hedging
along that close boarded fence
again just a different view of the site
just in this area here
the big garden currently has tables and
chairs spread out over the site
these could easily be moved into a more
confined space without causing a problem
with social distancing measures that are
in place at the moment
this shows the remaining big arden area
should members be
should approve the scheme so this is the
terrorist area just here the grassed
area
here and the play area the bull area
with the other tables and chairs are at
the front here that you can't quite see
this is the patio area just behind the
dining area
which also has tables and chairs
um this is the dwelling to the north of
the site that has
recently been constructed and is
considered to be backland development
uh one of the speakers today mr horn has
asked that
this photograph was shown to members
this was taken on monday which was the
first opening day of the pub
after uh the lockdown restrictions
um i think he wanted to point out that
it was quite a cold day
um but there was still a reasonable
level
of custom that were using the beer
garden at that stage
the heritage issues and highways
concerns the previous application
have been addressed by the new design of
the single dwelling
no harm to heritage assets have been
identified
and there is no intensification of the
access and therefore it would be
unreasonable to refuse the applications
for these reasons
environmental protection are content
that the mitigation measures to ensure
the immunity of future residents of the
proposed dwelling are protected
the remaining beer garden is considered
to be of an acceptable size to ensure
that it will not cause financial
viability issues to the smooth running
of the establishment it should be noted
that there is
no thoughts on closing the pub at all
it has reopened and is
will continue to stay open in its
current form
the proposed dwelling is a modest
bungalow in the centre of a key service
centre
it is within easy walking distance of
day-to-day facilities
and would be ideal for older or less
able-bodied residents to feel part of
the community
other than concerns raised over the
visibility displays
no objections have been raised from
statutory consultants
therefore this application is
recommended for approval with conditions
as set out on page 90
in your agenda thank you
thank you very much okay
um we've had all the information sorry
we've had uh thank you bring the
information to us i've just got a
question um in terms of environmental
health
um and the impact on the new
property in terms of having
a pub right next to it and a shared car
park
um i mean do they do they raise any
points
that need to be considered i mean you
know yes
so conflict between the two yes so
part of the mitigation measures are that
private immunity space in that courtyard
area
um also there is just one window that
faces onto the beer garden
uh which serves a bathroom so it's
unlikely that that would be
open for fresh air purposes when you're
sleeping at night for example when
you're likely to be disturbed by noise
uh also double glazing um was a
mitigation measure within the noise
assessment so that is an approved
document
which means that any measures that
that were found necessary are protected
um as an approved document so
what about keeping how how how do you
keep the car parking spaces for the
house rather than them being taken by
users of the pub so they are set back
slightly from
the rest of the car parking area um and
they're also
the surface material is a different
surface material so at the moment the
car park is tarmac
um and the proposed finishing surfacing
for
the dwelling um is a resin bound gravel
so it will be that pale sort of so
there's an element of good will
that people don't follow yeah there is
and i suspect that
you know signs or bollards might go
outside
if it becomes a problem okay thank you
and we've got some more questions
councillor mansell and then councillor
muller
uh thank you chair uh i've got a couple
of questions
um uh firstly i'd like a bit of
clarification
about the highways comment because uh
the planning office has just said that
there aren't any
major objections and yet in our papers
on page 82
um we have the highways summary comment
and it says that the highway authority
recommends that permission be refused
and it refers to the papers which i
think
um also uh they don't dispute the
summary on page 82 so i'd like a bit of
clarity about that
um and also um the planning officer
mentioned
some other open spaces where um village
um events might be held could we have
those pointed out on the
aerial photograph please yeah sure
you're right
um samantha did sam did talk about the
highways refused it but we can elaborate
a bit more
yeah that's fine sorry that was my cat
yeah so highways previously uh
objected to the application for the two
dwellings
where there were four parking spaces
that were required under current parking
standards
however this is a single dwelling and
there is
um just two parking spaces that are
required for a three-bedroom bungalow
uh three spaces will be lost
and two added by the dwelling so there's
actually a net loss of one
parking space overall on the site
therefore
we didn't feel that there was an
intensification of the use of the access
so when it comes to making a judgment on
highways grounds they have raised
issues around visibility space not that
they can't be achieved just that
they weren't actually received as part
of the application
however we felt that that was not
necessary to ask for that because
there's no intensification of use
of the access point so so have
highways come back um because presumably
this
reason there's a recommendation for
refusal was on the previous application
so is there a highway a written highways
comment to say that that no longer
applies
no there was an intensification of use
because there were more parking spaces
actually proposed with the last
application
because they haven't had another
reconsultation for this application
it didn't we didn't feel that it was
necessary to do that
and the other the other spaces for the
village events that you mentioned
i'll just get it up on here for you just
share my screen again
we saw one of the photographs a marquee
in the field next to the car park but
that's the primary school lab yeah that
is
yeah that's the primary school which is
another big open space that could be
used with permission
um but i think we were specifically
thinking about
parish uh functions so
um places within the village
quick click right so
uh the village hall i believe is just
here
it's probably a little bit difficult to
see because it's quite um a big area
that it's covering
um but the village hall is just here and
it's got this green
area just here to the rear of the
building that could be used
and also the millennium field which is
just in this area here
okay thank you help yeah okay yeah thank
you
councillor muller over to you um thank
you chair
actually councillor mansell has asked
the very question i was actually going
to ask myself and i'm satisfied with the
answer thank you very much
counselor
thank you very much mr chairman um has
there
been any work done um properly to show
that this
land is surplus to requirements uh
no viability statement was received with
uh
with the application i think the pub
felt that
nothing particularly was changing for
them as they have quite a lot of indoor
seating
and outdoor seating they just thought it
was
surplus space that could be when you say
the
um the pub you mean the owners yeah
punch ins are the owners
yes okay thank you thank you uh
counselor mansell uh sorry is that a no
that's not hand i think isn't it
that's did you want to come back
councilman
no okay cancer eben
um thank you very much chair thanks you
sam for the presentation
um i've got three questions or four
probably actually
um you've mentioned the hedge running
between
the proposed site and the um playing
field
and you you talked about a hedge being
retained but that looks pretty much
trees to me so will those trees be
retained and it won't be cut back to a
kind of six foot high hedge could you
confirm that um
secondly is there still access it's
quite hard to tell but i think possibly
is there still access to the beer garden
from the car park yeah um
thirdly noise um
my concern i haven't dealt with these as
a ward member is that the
people in the potentially this new house
will then
object to events or noise um and
there doesn't seem to be that much that
they've asked i think
um environmental health have asked for a
noise survey or something
um if you could just elaborate on that
and finally
um the
i'm still concerned about highways one
because it does that the
consultation does refer to this one
single story dwelling and saying that
they'd
recommend refusal but we can come back
to that but the other
one is the heritage i'm just quite
surprised that
heritage you're happy for a dwelling to
be
a meter away from a listed building um
could you just elaborate on on that
thank you very much yeah
okay no problem uh so yes all of the
tree
and hedging along that field boundary to
the primary school
is to be retained the access
from the car park would still be there
there's a small gap between
the two sites so people can still go
through this currently a gateway
there my understanding is that that will
remain
in terms of noise yeah you're quite
right a noise
assessment did actually come in with
this application we specifically asked
for that because of concerns
raised for future residents however
it was done at a time when we're in
lockdown so it's probably
not a true reflection of what's actually
going on
um but of course we have to try and keep
the planning process
going so at the moment we are accepting
uh applications on that basis
but it does mean that we will need
another noise survey to make sure that
all of the mitigation measures
that were outlined in the noise
assessment are actually carried out
and are effective for the future
residents so that's why
in your list of conditions we actually
have that as a another condition
but um another survey needs to be done
to ensure that all of the mitigation
measures are put in place
are and are effective for the residents
the highways one i know it's a really
tough one and
you know highways comes up with almost
every application
and sometimes you feel that they should
be objecting
when they don't and vice versa
and in this particular case it's the
vice versa situation
um because there is not an
intensification of use
of the access point because of the
number of car parking spaces
um it was felt unreasonable that we
asked for the visibility displays that
have been requested
from uh suffolk highways um so on this
occasion
we're using our common sense and
uh with the traffic assessment that's
already been
uh provided by the applicant we're
making a judgment
uh as planning officers on that issue
in this particular instance doesn't
happen all the time mostly we do go with
highways
recommendations but because there is no
intensification
it felt that it was not a necessary
requirement for this one
and in terms of heritage the
the applicant did have pre-application
advice with both myself
and the heritage team uh we discussed
what would be
acceptable um and we felt that
something very low-key that reflected an
outbuilding that probably was previously
there
and shown on the historic maps would be
acceptable
and that's where their reasoning comes
with no harm to the listed building
in this instance thanks very much for
that thank you
thank you uh next up is councilman
yeah i'm also uncomfortable with this
situation with with the highways
um i mean they really ought to come back
with with a
specific
did you say they've come back and said
they don't want to change their view
no no what they just haven't come yeah i
didn't reconsult them because there was
no information to reconsult them on that
basis
so um because we didn't ask for the
visibility displays
because when you go out on site you can
make that judgment yourself
um and you know when i did my site visit
you can
see clearly left and right
and it is in a 30 mile an hour speed
limit
yeah what i wanted to ask really then
was was the
you know how we assess intensification
only the um the use of the
potential property will be quite
different to the use of the pub
in terms of when the traffic is
generated and that sort of thing
and how do we um how do they how do
highways or we
assess intensification in that sense
then
um i can't tell you how highways would
do it i
i have looked at it from the point of
view that the pub will probably be
open from midday until 11 o'clock at
night
and in that time frame those 20 parking
spaces are going to be
used coming and going frequently i would
assume
with someone that's living in the
village and that close to facilities
so the primary school is literally next
door the co-op is just about
probably 200 yards away from from the
actual dwelling
so anyone using those day-to-day
facilities would be
uh probably walking rather than driving
um so then you have probably
two two or three people that would be
going out to work
um so yeah i think
the the trips
would be minimal is is my opinion
thank you councillor field
thank you a couple of things really
um the historic maps do you have those
available because
the last time i looked at developments
in this area in the historic maps
i'm not sure that i noticed the uh the
things that you're
imagining um so i wondered if i
we're there the millennium field you
mentioned is that
actually within the parish council's
ownership because i know the county is
trying to do
an amount of development there and
there's various questions about who that
land belongs to
so i wondered if you confirm that um
and on the viability you mentioned that
there won't be an impact on viability i
wasn't clear from your subsequent
statements
who that information came from is that
punch taverns or the current
um tenant or whoever
and you also mentioned that the land
retain will be half of the existing and
yet the plans you showed didn't seem to
imply that i wonder if you
could look at those plans again and
demonstrate it to us
thank you okay sorry what was your first
point again i just missed that one
the historic story you've mentioned do
you actually have votes available
yeah i'm afraid that i don't have those
uh that they were looked at as part of
the consultation
with heritage so that's something that
they have mentioned
in their consultation response actually
um
in terms of the millennium field uh
i don't know whose ownership that that
is within
um but it's my understanding that that
is
somewhere that can be used by the by the
parish
for functions um viability
um by ability didn't actually form part
of this application the pub is not
closing
so it's not something that we
particularly needed
um and as you can see already the pub
has reopened
and is serving people so um
yeah no viability was actually uh
received and therefore we assumed that
it was not
part of the application but saying that
the applicant
will be all the agent will be speaking
later and perhaps that's a question that
they might be able to answer more fully
than i'm able to
um and sorry the last point oh half of
the garden
that's right yeah i did do a quick
measurement so the red line actually
incorporates part of the car park
so i think that's why it looks a bit
different when i said it's
about half of the um the the beer garden
that would be taken up with the dwelling
so um the site area within
the beer garden itself excluding the
access point
and the uh car parking area that would
be taken
is 535 square meters
uh the remaining beer garden for the pub
is 568 square meters
okay thank you very much um
we don't have any other hands up so
thank you for that
we'll now move on to the parish
representative and the public speaking
and first up we have caroline walton
welcome to the meeting and if you could
turn your camera on thank you
and you have three minutes to address
the committee thank you mr chairman
branford parish council strongly object
and request you decline this application
and it is not compliant with
nppf and the reasons for the planning
refusal on this site
in august 2020 have still not been
addressed and still stand
brantford is a core village and is
growing rapidly we have had an increase
of 65 percent of housing granted
near 650 homes with more pending
so to remove the outdoor space at our
one surviving pub
is not supportive of the community or
the business itself
outdoor spaces community places is
paramount especially with current
restrictions and people's apprehension
of socializing indoors
if you were to approve this build we
believe the business will not be
profitable
and fail leaving the village with no
public house
nppf paragraph 92 states planning should
guard against
unnecessary loss of facilities and
ensure established facilities are able
to grow and develop
and states its aims to preserve
community facilities
this application does neither we believe
this build is not sustainable
and will cause conflicts between
occupants of the home and patrons of the
pub due to noise and disturbance and
long opening hours
this pub regular has live events outdoor
barbecues and community fates etcetera
mppf states a new development should be
integrated effectively with existing
business and community facilities
and should not have unreasonable
restrictions placed on them because of a
new development
this was a reason for refusal at the
last application
and nothing has changed we are also
hugely concerned by the safety of the
residents of the proposed home
that have no safe pedestrian access to
the property
there is no path access only by walking
driving through the centre of the pub
car park
can you gain access to it mppf paragraph
110
states plans must give priority to
pedestrians and cycle movements
and minimize conflict between them this
plan does not and as a result we feel
lives are at risk with calves and
servicing lawrence attending the pub
throughout the day
again this was a reason for refusal at
the last application
and again this matter has not changed
visibility splays at junction are not in
accordance with manual for streets
guidance and highways recommend refusal
of this plan as a result
not to mention the very narrow footpath
of 0.8 meters on either side of the
street at this location that also
includes a bus stop and bin collection
point at the junction
the public house is a registered asset
of community value which highlights to
you its importance to our growing
community
at one time brantford had eight pubs
this is our last remaining
pub and must be supported to survive and
thrive
not to be put at risk by one small
in-field home when branford has already
supported so much growth
a core village must provide and protect
its community facilities
therefore we urge you to please refuse
this application and support our
community in maintaining its pub garden
for future generations to come
thank you
thank you very much for that um do we
have any questions at all
yes counselor manson uh thank you chair
um um i i'm very interested to hear that
the
pub um has been registered as an asset
of community value
can you tell me whether that is just the
pub building or whether it's the whole
grounds of the pub that are listed as a
an asset of community value
we've registered the entire site so the
pub and its grounds and their facilities
and and the pub itself so if it was to
come up for sale then it would be past
the community to purchase
we'd have first refusal thank you
so so can i just follow up on counselor
mansell's question then um
so so if that's the case can um can we
just have clarity from the legal team
i mean if you separate off i mean how
come the
the parish doesn't get the right to buy
the land that the house is going on
uh as a separate option because it's
part of the pub which is an asset of
community value
and they're effectively stripping away
some of the asset of community value
so chairman the the the significance in
planning terms of the registration of
any
any um institute place
a building or land associated with as an
asset of community value
as an asset of community value is that
that that
registration that fact is is a material
consideration to which you must have
regard when you're making planning
decisions however
it doesn't prevent the
um it doesn't enable
um or require the owner of the of the
establishment in question doesn't
require them to sell at all or to sell
to anybody
and it doesn't re i mean it may although
the acv registration may have some
effect on valuation
quite possibly it doesn't really
interfere with with any other
pro private law process
okay thank you
any other questions before we move on no
okay thank you very much for joining us
today um we'll now move on
to an objector mr albert horn and mr one
if you could turn your ah sorry
councillor field your hand's gone up
well i was just going to question the
the the officer then
he mentioned that the asset of community
value
registration doesn't um doesn't if you
like insist
that the um owner then sells the
property in any way but
i thought the principle was that if they
choose to sell the property
then the the um local community gets
uh first refusal um and clearly
uh he will be selling an element of this
element of land
so should not the community have first
refused them
you're on mute in i'm sorry councillor
hicks sorry i was on i was on them
uh on news i didn't realize it i will
double check the law in the
uh now but i don't the short i i don't
think
as far i have looked at this in the past
quite recently for this council
i don't think that it it it
certainly the owner can i don't think
the owner
can be required to sell to any
particular personal group but i will
if you would like me to while the next
speaker is speaking
i mean i think the thing is is is is if
if you're selling off some of the land
which is part of the community asset
well
can i can i come in please uh ultimately
there is nothing to stop the owner
subdividing the piece of land or the
building
as much as they want in terms of what
parts they sell
the point here though the whole lot is
registered on that basis
as they are sold the first dibs as the
parish representation said goes to the
community first
uh if they are unable to purchase
whatever the price might be
of that peace then that would move on
beyond that
um that's essentially the process that
that particular legislation provides
okay so if they get planning permission
for this piece of land
the value of the land increases indeed
and the value the value can be set at
any any level
by the odor over there unfortunately
we're we're dealing with market
mechanics
versus the councils uh thank you for the
long community
okay thank you very much i will now move
on welcome mr horn thank you for joining
us
and over to you and you have three
minutes to address the committee
thank you i'd suggest that any
development in the garden of listed
building in this case the [ __ ]
would have an impact on the visual
setting of the building this proposal
would also affect the setting of lifters
numbers
6 8 and 10 the street opposite which
would be visible through the small area
of garden which would
remain to the side of the pub pedestal
access to the proposed building would be
through the public car park this is
inappropriate
the nppf program 108 as caroline said i
believe states developments must provide
safe and suitable access for all users
the visibility emerging from the car
park is poor especially with the
proximity to the junction
just because some people slow down and
to get around the junction doesn't mean
that safe is quite the opposite
with such close proximity to the pub
noise is likely to be an issue for any
purchasers especially if they have live
events outside
and they are likely to complain setting
the viability of the pub
the public house is an essential
facility for the village and surrounding
area
it is the last remaining public house in
the british after the loss of
the bell the royal oaks three tons white
home crown ball princess arms ships and
angel float and little black and have no
pub support and wild man is currently
closed there's no obvious prospect of it
reopening
it is officially now set to community
community barrier
mppf paragraph 92 aims to preserve
community facilities planning policies
and decisions should guard against the
unnecessary loss of facilities and
ensure that
established facilities are able to
develop modernized and enhanced
the proposed development would lead to
loss of public car parking and beer
garden both vital to the village park
the latter more so in the time of covert
restrictions
the village does still have the bomb for
the district social club and the tiny
size of its garden means it's currently
unable to open
if the cop had already lost as much of
its garden as proposed here i'd suggest
that it would also be unviable to reopen
this week
the pub was mentioned as an important
british asset in recent large
scale housing development applications
so is presumably a factor in them being
granted
recent developments include 115 runnings
at fitzgerald road 198 willowbrook and
hundreds more for its extension
fourteen at river hills springfield and
twenty are bypassed nurseries bronford
road
they should provide more trade for the
pub in the future but it should all
shall be noted
that these were generally against the
wishes of the current villages there
were over 150 objections to this
proposal
so we are looking to support at the
villages of branford
i'm amazed that this has just been put
forward saying it'd be suitable for old
people to totter through
car park to get to the co-op i don't
think so
um as former chairman of the parish
council i've never heard of the area
called milgreen or millfield which
you've called it although i can see
nowhere on the map what you mean
this was intensively used when locked
down was lifted during the summer
with horrific consequences of litter and
so on and it wouldn't be properly used
out for a public event
i don't think goodwill already comes
into it and people are leaving a pub and
they're not parked their car in the
right place this will cause problems
um a historic possible outbuilding is
not the same as a dreading place
um i don't think the pub is open from
midday non-stop until 11 o'clock so
there will be a um
added intensity there and i'm not
certain but i did hear i
have to ask you to last sentence please
the time is up
thank you um i have heard that some of
those trees mentioned have gone you
might be able to see better in the
photos that
caroline sent you because i'm not
certain of that thank you very much
thank you uh we have john madison you uh
council madison a question
thank you mr horn yes um i suspect
you've been
living in the village for a good number
of years can you
just um outline to the committee the
um the tensions and difficulties that
resulted from the noise issue
at the um british legion a few years ago
which
came before the planning committee um
when i'm ready
sorry i'm i'm not i'm not sure about the
relevance we can only look at the
application that's before us today
so i think the my my sense of the
relevance is that
um of the diff the problems that would
be
created within the village um the
tensions within the village i think is
the point
um uh which which arose on that occasion
but we're only looking at today's
application
i'm not sure i i can find a link a noise
from a pre i mean i'll ask ian to come
in and comment well it's i think if
is counselor matheson my concern that
some recent village history indicates
that there would be
a problem of a similar kind if this
permission were granted is that the
issue
i i think mr pray has the point exactly
thank you well i think may i may i
suggest that
if we if the council let councillor
madison put the question then i'll
if i really if i really think it is
irrelevant i'll advise you accordingly
chairman but
thank you yeah the full question yeah
yeah well my my question is can you
can you just um advise
the committee as to the problems that
may arise again um in terms of tensions
within the village
just briefly
treasurer of the social club i can
confirm that large amounts of money were
spent
um sound proofing and that we were not
allowed to open the rear doors
while music was on um and it put the
viability to the club in serious doubt
and
if we were not allowed to have doors
open
um at the pub it would have a similar
effect and also yes there was a lot of
tension between
people saying oh these people have moved
to the village now they're complaining
about the noise what they knew was next
door
yeah thank you okay thank you
um any other questions at all
no okay thank you very much for joining
us today um
we now move on to um the agent uh lauren
parsons
uh you if you could turn your camera on
please and you have three minutes as
well
to address the committee ah
thank you good afternoon counselors your
cameras your camera's not on
there we go thank you
i would like to thank you for the
opportunity to speak at this planning
committee meeting
i represent punch partnerships pml
limited the applicant and owner of the
clock in public house as the council's
planning officer has outlined
the proposal is the one three-bedroom
single-story dwelling
on an area of land severed from the
pub's large outdoor amenity area
the site is in a sustainable location
being within the village settlement
boundary
the proposed about the prose dwelling
will be located behind the public house
which will limit views of it from the
street
two car parking spaces and a cycle store
are proposed for the development
which complies with local local parking
standards
the pub will still retain an outdoor
amenity space after the implementation
of the proposals
and will continue to trade as a viable
business
noise from the public house will be
mitigated through design features
including a brick wall
between the amenity area and the
proposed house
and ensuring that all openings are on
the house face away from the beer garden
this will ensure there will be no
negative impact from noise on the
residential immunity
of the future occupiers of the dwelling
the
heritage objection from the previous
application the two dwellings was
overcome
in the current application by following
advice from the heritage officer
in the pre-application dwelling has been
designed to be subservient
public house creating the appearance of
an outbuilding relationship
a traditional material palette will be
used to respect
the heritage of the pub setting this
includes barn light materials
such as soft red brick plinth
with timber weatherboard clouding and
slate roof tiles
detailing is to be simple and avoid
domestic finishes
the application has adopted a
fabric-first approach to sustainability
any construction will be highly
insulated and double and triple glazing
will be used to reduce heat loss as well
as overheating
the property will be heated by an
efficient air source
heat pump system to provide a
sustainable
sustainable
alternative to gas powered heating
energy saving
and energy efficient appliances will be
installed across the development
such as energy efficient light fittings
low water usage sanitary products
and materials with low embodied energy
the scheme is supported by the planning
case officer and heritage
environmental health and land
contamination statutory consultants
the councillors are therefore
respectfully asked to follow the advice
of its expert planning officers
and grant planning permission for
development thank you
thank you very much we've got uh several
questions that have gone up
can i just uh just uh take chairman's
prerogative and just ask quick question
um so the owner of the pub is punch-ins
um what about the landlord what is their
view
on losing half the garden not the owner
i'm talking about the landlord your
tenanted
um i have not received any
correspondence from the landlord
concerning the development
right so they don't support it but they
don't oppose it
okay thank you uh councillor passmore
uh thank you matthew um lauren thank you
for presentation
one of the areas i'd just like to ask
you um if we look at the report
regarding residential amenity for the
proposed dwelling
and noise and so on what measures would
be taken to minimize the noise if um
let's say if this house were to go ahead
people sitting out in the garden
sunbathing and all sorts of things
there's
the view there should be an element of
privacy but the noise
issue there is one that um i'd like a
little more explanation how can we make
sure that people
don't have their immunity destroyed if
they want to set out in the garden
having a barbecue or just sitting there
sunbathing quietly for example
sorry my internet just dropped out now
can you please clarify what the question
was
yeah the the question is how would you
what are the proposals for mitigation
mitigating the noise from the pub
i i get the part that there's there
about double glazing software actually
inside the building but also
ones in the garden if they were there um
wanted to quite sunbathing or whatever
doesn't matter what it is the fact is
you don't necessarily want a whole load
of noise
in the garden so what measures would
there be for privacy and um and noise
mitigation in the garden
and we're proposing a brick wall and a
hedge between
the application site and the pub spear
garden which will help to mitigate the
noise
thank you uh counselor manson
uh thank you chair um um and thank you
mr parsons um could you please just
uh confirm for me uh about the cycle
storage
uh area which you mentioned uh because i
can find no
indication on any of the plans uh that i
can see
about where that is whether that's
internal or
thank you local area will be just behind
the in the
back garden and is it undercover
or is it just uh just open air
no it will be undercover um but but that
isn't on our plan
so we can't um we we've got a bit of
uncertainty about that because that's
not in the plans that we've been given
sorry it's on the um landscaping plan um
it's labelled
inside the store the case office is
going to just come in and comment
okay would it be helpful if i if i
showed you the plan
yes please
has has the has it come up yes it has
yes
so is this area here just to the rear of
the building that grey building just
there
thank you okay the access down is that a
part
that goes between the hedge and
the house and the wall or whatever
that's where the bicycles would access
that shed
yes that's correct and the access to the
beer garden is exactly the same on the
other side of that hedge
through that gap there yeah
okay um come on no other hands up could
i just ask a question and
how do you avoid the conflict of
a car if people drive to the pub from
some distance and they get there
and the car parks full but they're two
residence bays
how do you stop that conflict between
people just using them
i mean as the case officer mentioned
earlier we have used a different
material to try and differentiate
but um we'd be happy to have the
planning conditions
secured which would make it more
restrictive for parking to make it
clearer
right okay thank you any other questions
at all
okay thank you very much for joining us
today thank you very much
okay so we now move on to the ward
member councillor james caston
welcome and over to you thank you very
much mr chairman
um thank you committee members um the
original part of the brantford
[ __ ] was built in 1604 it's been the
center of village life for
generations there was an old puzzle the
[ __ ] doesn't crow the bell doesn't ring
the yolk doesn't grow
and the angel doesn't sing where am i it
was branford
the other pubs unfortunately have shut
down the
angel shut down quite recently 2011.
it leaves just the branford [ __ ] and i
strongly believe that this development
will make this great british pub
impossible to save
for reasons that i will come to later
the brantford [ __ ] is really important
it's the only village pub
open within a three and a half kilometer
radius
and what's kept this pub open all this
time
it must have something special about it
a usp
i'm sure the space that they offer in
the beer garden
is um a factor in this um
and there's more space if you include
the um children's playground
this is only rivaled by the sorrell
horse in byram
a pub that's managed to stay viable
although
over a kilometer away from the massive
barham
and until recently only surrounded by a
few houses
why because of its large beer garden
the when the sun comes out people
want to travel and sit outside and
socialize
this brings in customers and tourism
in brantford a number of people travel
from ipswich
and baber areas to spend their money in
mid-suffolk
in the summer the british public are
prepared to travel
for this kind of space and also need
a place to park when they get there
but why would the pubs owners want to do
this
their business model needs to utilize
every asset
to pay their debts that they carry they
will
they we need to do what's right by this
asset
it's been around for over 400 years
owners have been the custodians
and this great asset has been kept alive
mid-suffolk has always done its best by
pubs and i don't feel that i'm being
dramatic when i say this
seriously diminishes the viability of
this pub
the area of the beer garden has been
perfectly suited to covered restrictions
and has an advantage over surrounding
pubs
the world health organization and many
others say there will be future
pandemics
we have no reason to believe that
similar restrictions won't be about in
the future
and um it's interesting that the
planning system today was born
from the disease prevention act
but um i want to look at the suitability
of this site against a very small
housing delivery
we we have development in the village
we're providing for
300 we're we have free planning
applications
currently between outline and reserve
matters they're set to provide
over 300 homes including many houses of
this type
and have a consultation starting on
another major development
as district councillor i've received a
noise complaint
on the 30th of september in 2020
that was um officially taken to the
environmental health
from a property over 20 meters away
this house will be zero meters away from
the pub beer garden
the um the pub backs on to the primary
the um bungalow backs onto the primary
school field
but noise is a concern picture june
children shouting and playing during the
day and after school clubs
there might possibly be an hour's piece
until the pub opens and customers
squeeze into the now
around 200 meters squared beer garden
and the noise starts again until 11
o'clock
and let's face it volume control is not
always at the forefront
of people's minds in fact
you'll you often hear calls of i'll see
you later or you forgot your phone
shouted across a beer garden probably
the noisiest part of the evening's
interaction as people are leaving
i don't know many pubs that don't
experience these issues
but potentially a couple of meters away
from a
child's bedroom is not ideal
it's not really the pub's fault because
the the pubs been there for a long time
how can we deal with this issue how do
we deal with
adults having an adult conversation
without a single child
in sight when there is actually young is
listening the other side of a hedge
bedroom three is the most likely one to
be used by the youngest child in a
family
and it is literally just a couple of
meters away from the area people leave
the beer garden by
so how do we deal with this we have
double glazed windows you can't open and
vents to allow the
air into the property
um this this is a potential scenario
people
get woken up in this house mid suffolk
environmental health come out
the sign goes up as usual for people to
leave quietly
maybe a few restrictions two months
later
just one person wakes up
the family again and the business cannot
be run
under this pressure this is without
other problems for the lunchtime trade
when there's
a building site and deliveries coming in
it
it is impossible to give the pedestrians
first priority
as required in paragraph 110 of the mppf
also in the mppf
paragraph 83 we are to support
a prosperous rural economy with
retention of
accessible services and community
facilities such as public houses
paragraph 92 which was mentioned earlier
planning policy
should plan positively for the provision
of shared public spaces
and public houses and guard against
unnecessary loss of valued facilities
the planning system is not just to
protect social immunity
it also protects the further
future dweller of this house it could be
quiet when the person moves in but in
the summer
it could be possibly be like having
people sitting in your front garden
talking
every night of the week i would ask
councillors
to protect this pub from being run into
the ground for profit
and by removing an asset that is not
has not been proved to be surplus to
requirements
highways have not removed their
recommendation for refusal
it's had no viability study
and this i strongly believe that this
house is really unsuitable for the site
and gives so little benefit for housing
need
thank you and mr chairman for bearing
with me um
thank you very much um uh okay
questions for the ward member councillor
passmore uh thank you matthew and then
um hello james your afternoon james just
from your
perspective as the ward member i do know
the pub having
lived in this area for so many years
what would you say
its potential would be going forward um
for
improving the ambience and everything
and how would that be compromised
uh by putting a house there seems to me
there's a lot of potential these places
in the offer and i don't know what the
fabric of the building is like etc
but what i do believe is that if there
is given potential
with food the beers the drinks etc the
general ambience
um do you think it could be improved and
how do you think the
if we were to give permission for
another house how would that be
compromised
so i think i think it's really good now
i'm a councillor passed more there's a
there's a new um landlady in there it's
um
i did actually go down there the night
of the
when the restrictions were lifted and um
there's a really good buzz
in the air the um the potential for
that pub in the future is um to be a hub
of the um village like it is now there's
um
there's an orchard being created in
brantford
we've already talked about having a day
of um pressing apples
for for the local people in a large big
on you can't do those sort of things
inside
the um also with the um with the large
beer garden area
you do find that you get um
people in their groups talking whilst
children
run around inside a safe environment is
it
it's fenced in they everyone can keep an
eye
on them um it works really well i think
the big problem with having this
bungalow built
is it's so close to where people will be
talking having discussions and
let's face it sometimes later on at
night
people do have quite um
quite um fruity discussions and maybe um
a little bit of um debate over things
people will be laying in their beds
listening to
these conversations and they're just not
suitable for people that haven't chosen
to go to a um
a beer garden to listen okay yeah thank
you
thank you that answers that question
thank you
any other question for the ward member
no okay thank you for joining us um okay
members so it's over to us to discuss
debate
and reach a conclusion
our counselor field your first step
second time i i sometimes sit and listen
to the
presentations at these meetings and
wonder what planet
people are living on but to this
for this application i've heard three
sets of
presentations that seem totally correct
um
you know particularly uh council casting
has covered all the points
um and the the parish council points
were totally significant
um we we do seem to be being asked to
damage a significant
asset for the benefit of um
punch tavern's uh financial position
right at this moment which we all have
great sympathy with but but should we be
destroying the future for that
uh perhaps i wonder are we just um
if we go out planning permission do we
just increase the price the parish
council will have to pay
for this bit of land to prevent anything
happening
that's one way of getting um sil money
out of
parish pockets i guess but i think to
concentrate on my real concerns uh
it's a matter of the um the impact on
the
the viability of the pub we've heard
that
from the from the people my
presentations
clearly reducing the area of the beer
garden is going to
affect the the pubs viability quite
substantially particularly at the moment
but but
as um councillor caster mentioned in a
you know
on a longer term basis such a garden
does allow
families to to come to to the
establishment and
that's essential if we want them to
continue so there's a dramatic impact
there that
the comments about conversations and
noise and and the inappropriateness of
conversations uh that might be going on
at 10 or 11 o'clock at night to the
to young ears absolutely vital
i think um the impact of the parking as
well
as we heard you know we would be adding
1 600
to the number of houses that branford is
accepting at the moment
that's a tiny proportion to the totality
we're losing only two or three parking
places but clearly the need for parking
increases i've always noticed the car
park is particularly full
we're talking about putting more houses
at the periphery of the village
where people are less likely to walk in
and as
as we said this is a is a this is a
really pleasant
pub that people come to from ipswich and
babur and god knows where else
um so there seemed to be a tremendous
amount of
possibility for uh negative impact
the last time we sat and discussed such
a thing it was about the angel where we
we decided we would put dwellings in its
car park
and uh it's now closed perhaps that's a
bad
you know a wrong parallel to draw but i
think that's
um it's significant i i find i'm
really against this it's it seems to be
tremendous
damage to the exactly the sort of
facilities we all need for our mental
health in in
the immediate future and the long-term
future
so thank you i won't make a present uh
proposal yet but uh okay i'm just going
to bring
in um mr indepress just put his hand up
just uh just to see if there's something
we need to well yes
thank you i i wasn't intending to speak
further but i i will
just because councillor feels made the
point i if we may just go back to the
assets of community value issue in which
i have
checked the law just yeah um and the key
point is as i said originally you
um where there isn't
an asset of community value registered
the local planning authority and
considering a planning application
relating to
the site must treat it as a material
consideration though
as as we always advise you the weight to
be attached to that is a matter for your
plan that's the key principle i'm in a
way reluctant to add anything further
that might detract from
yeah but however i will just say that i
have double checked and
the the the practical consequence of a
registration is that there is if
the owner wants to sell the asset and i
i think
as far as i can ascertain from a quick
reminder of a look at the law
this applies to a sale of part of the
land there is a moratorium period indeed
as my colleague said
which is it's well without going to
great detail it's it's in total six
months
um but it it is intended to allow a
community group to raise some money
but it does not oblige the owner of the
asset
to sell um either even if they're the
only the community group or the only
bidder or the or the highest bidder
it it's so but there it is for what it's
worth
thank you very much okay cancer possible
um
thank you chairman um i am i've listened
to all the arguments and i am concerned
about this application so i'm going to
propose a rejection on the grounds i do
think it will be removing
um a facility a community asset call it
what you will
a business i think it potentially could
ruin it
by putting an extra house up so i don't
agree with the assessment that it
wouldn't have any impact i think it will
have an impact
and we need to do what we can to support
the pub industry as a whole
the fact that the highways have made
their comments as well i think needs to
be taken into account
and i believe by putting this one
dwelling there it is only one after all
as we've heard
it will potentially compromise future
development of the pub as a business
by restricting car parking we all know
you do need to have good parking
available as well as a good uh
offer commercial offer from the pub um
we can argue it's a moot point about the
setting of an historic building one way
or the other i think it would be a very
retrograde step to allow
a modern house to be um put in the
ground so therefore uh chairman
there's the assets there's the highways
there's the business potential
the noise is something i'm seriously
concerned about particularly outside
ambience
so therefore i support all the comments
from um the ward member
of the councillors and the parish
council and uh therefore
i am moving to refuse this application
on those grounds
thank you very much councillor mansell
uh thank you chair i i i completely uh
for once agree
with uh much of what uh council password
said so i will uh be quite happy to
second
um his proposal um to refuse this
application
um um you know i think now is not the
time
to be halving the size of a pub garden
when we need to be
uh we want to encourage the business to
grow and we
need to be outside and socially distant
from other people
but one thing that hasn't yet been
mentioned is the pedestrian access
to this dwelling um i i think that
um walking through a pub car park
uh as your main pedestrian access to and
from your front door
um is uh not um conducive to
um people wanting to walk anywhere uh
unfortunately in this country
where there's a propensity for people to
drive forwards into parking spaces
uh and often when reversing uh people
don't
sort of spot pedestrians walking behind
the car so the fact that anyone walking
to or from this house will have to be
going past the backs of cars that could
potentially be reversing uh in front of
them in their way
um i think that also needs to be added
to the
um reasons for refusal is i don't think
there is safe pedestrian access
uh to and from this dwelling house uh
but
so if that if that's added well i'm
still happy to second anyway
but i wonder whether council password
would be willing to add the the issue of
pedestrian
safe pedestrian access as well may i
come in on that yes
please do please do i i would
find that very hard to defend given that
the public house
area is open to the public and you have
members of the public
walking around that area currently in
conflict with cars also parking for the
public use
i can't distinguish between someone
going to their house versus someone
going to the pub through the same car
park because the access to the pub
is on the side which accesses directly
onto the car park
as well as the side entrance to the pub
which is also to the car parks people
can't separate the two
i would find that very difficult to
argue in an appeal situation
to robustly defend that point it would
be
exceedingly difficult in my opinion but
i can only offer you my opinion
okay could i could i just come back on
that please do um
in the people have a choice about
whether they go to a pub
um if they want to access their front
door i i think that actually is
is actually a right i think they have a
right to walk to and from their front
door
uh they have a choice about whether they
go to a pub or not
and that is the difference in mind yeah
can i just add to cancer mance's point i
mean if you look at page 108 under the
reasons for refusal of that one
one of the things was the unsafe
pedestrian vehicle access arrangement
between the residential and commercial
interface
which isn't that what this is but this
has
yeah although this has changed i haven't
got sight of the arrangement under the
two dwellings that were refused
uh versus this um to see the difference
between the two
same interface maybe but okay well let's
if you if you want to just look that up
with sam and we'll just keep going and
we'll come back to that point at the end
councillor mayor
thanks chair um i personally think that
the noise is a little bit of a red
herring here in that if you look to
the south of the pub there is already a
house there that
doesn't benefit from a brick wall that
doesn't
benefit from design criteria that
creates
a enclosed patio and noise isn't an
issue
there so i personally don't have a
problem with the noise
i do have a problem with the access it
was rejected on access grounds before
and i think councilwoman was quite right
to highlight the access through the car
clock is far from ideal
i think viability is an interesting
issue
punch taverns own the pub and it's in
their
interest to maximize their return i very
much doubt if the landlord's going to
see a reduction in rent
so from punch tavern's point of view
this makes sense
i was interested to hear from the
district councillor that
it's a new landlord if i was a new
landlord would i object
to something my owners wanted to do no i
probably wouldn't
so i think we've got to be a little bit
careful around viability
i i think the viability of the blood
will be affected
and i don't think we should be surprised
that the current landlord hasn't
um said otherwise and from punch
talent's point of view
they look to maximum minus their return
i did question whether we can class it
as a community asset
in that it's a privately owned piece of
land that has in the past been used for
events
i can use my garden for a public event
that doesn't give the
local community um rights over how it's
used
i'm extremely surprised that heritage
think this is um
acceptable i'm actually going to keep
this diagram because
i live in a listed house and if i want
to build something within two meters of
my list of property
i have no doubt that they'd object um
robustly
so i shall keep this diagram just to use
as perhaps a little bit of evidence for
the future
so on balance i i returned to the
original
um rejection and i don't think it
delivers it only till there was very
modest economic and
social advantages and i think there's a
significant downside to this and
actually you could use exactly the same
refusal and just
remove that one sentence about listed um
building
um being harmful because heritage don't
support it so i i don't think very much
has changed and
i'll be recommending or um voting
against
thank you um everyone's hands have gone
up yeah i absolutely agree
um i i i i'm i think it's a bit
disappointing this application has come
forward
at this location because it it feels to
me as if
this is just this this isn't a house
that's being built that's going to
provide
a home that that's going to be easy to
live in
it's going to have conflict i think with
the residents you want to have your
windows open in the summer but if you
have children can you open your windows
at 11 o'clock at 10 o'clock at night for
young children when the beer garden's
full of people i think that's a conflict
the car parking is clearly going to be a
conflict
um and i think the viability the pub is
going to be conflicted by
uh using up so much of the space so for
me um
as all the reasons that councillor
passmore and others have said i
i totally agree i don't think this is uh
an appropriate use of this land and i
think it's
it's um it's not it's not something i'll
be supporting
so um john pate madrid you've heard
various reasons uh that people have put
forward
um you've heard um a couple of added
things
do you just want to run over what you've
got and then we'll come back to council
password and counselor mansell
just just to get their views as they
proposed and seconded
okay i i missed the second decision
that's all definitely seconded right
okay
thank you um
right uh let's see
um i have been jotting things down as
we've gone
along and uh
there's quite a few bits and pieces in
respect to the
viability noise uh and other aspects to
try and kind of
wrap them up into something that's clear
so
i've tried to do it this way i've
actually got
two reasons uh for refusal to suggest
for members consideration the first is
to say simply this um the subdivision
and loss of part of the beer garden
would likely impact
the people i don't know if we talked
about financial viability sufficiently i
might
need to withdraw that but i'll say any
start again the
subdivision and loss of part of the beer
garden would likely impact the financial
viability and function of the public
house by reducing
the outdoor dining drinking area and
therefore limiting the number of
customers that the public house could
serve
this would be detrimental to its valued
contribution to the community and local
employment
in addition the development would
further enclose the public house leading
to
potential increase concerns of
concentrated noise
and disturbance in a decreased bayer
garden area
acting as an unnecessary form of
significant restraint
on the current business operation and
viability
it is considered that the benefits of a
single dwelling would not outweigh these
material issues and on this basis
the proposal is contrary to policies e6
h17 and the aims of paragraphs
8 80 and 92 of the nppf
my second reason to suggest to members
would be that
taking on board at the point about the
commercial interface
between the residential property and
commercial
use the development would result in
unsafe pedestrian and vehicular access
arrangement
create an inappropriate residential
commercial interface
and the proposed development would
result in an intensification of use of
substantive
substandard stat access failing to
demonstrate appropriate visibility
displays can be achieved
and there is therefore is considered to
be a significant risk to highway safety
contrary to policy t10 and
paragraph 108 and 109 of the nppf
thank you very much um council password
counselor manchester are you happy
with that yes thank you matthew
absolutely fine councilman
yeah yeah thank you uh i'm glad the bit
about pedestrians has gone in because
i've just checked the other
the previous application so thank you
for that
thank you very much casterfield do you
just have your hand up before we go to a
vote
just there was nothing in there about
the fact that
we are having regard to the fact it's a
asset of community
value and so resistant is it can
john can you come here yes um obviously
it's a material consideration
um what i would suggest then if i put so
the subdivision and
loss of part of the beer garden that is
a community
uh that is a huge
asset of community
value which would be therefore a point
to make
any appeal that is a i said
an asset an asset sorry
an asset of community value would likely
to yeah okay i've got that in there
thank you you're happy with that uh
cancer personal counselor mansour
yes yes okay so we'll go to the vote
uh councillor matheson yeah i just um
just tried to help help mr payman gee i
think the the point about the asset
community value is
it's in there the community recognizing
recognizing thank you yeah um halfway
through that paragraph i have put that
it would be a detrimental to its valued
contribution to the community and local
employment um
so that draws that point out even
further as you go through the refusal
okay thank you oh we send that over to
bob
okay so uh i'll now hand over
to um
claire you're taking us through the vote
today sorry claire
uh claire pott yes thank you chair i
will
um do the vote rob is just updating it
for us
okay and i will let you know when we are
ready
i've just sent it over now so hopefully
you've got that
thank you
foreign
[Music]
okay members if i can ask you to go to
the plus sign on your mod gov
app and select voting
i will now the vote is now in progress
so again four is refusal
against
it's not
thank you members chair that's eight
votes
for okay so the application
is refused okay members um
yes council matheson yeah just to
mention there's a couple of stray words
at the end of that
um which one removing when the minutes
and things are done yeah thank you
okay uh thanks everyone thanks very much
um we don't have any site inspection
requests to be reported to committee
do we i'm sure we don't no chair we
don't
no we don't great okay so thank you very
much happy to close the meeting at 1 15.
thanks everyone for joining us and have
a good afternoon
you